This is Jocko podcast number one 44 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening and a few episodes back.
I referenced an interview that I had read with Colonel David Hackworth,
the author about face,
my,
my favorite book of all time check and it was actually on on podcast number one
42 and I referenced this interview and I said I'd cover it in the future on a
podcast.
So here we are,
one 40 for the interview is from pbs.org they had a show called people's century
and inside that show,
inside that series,
there was one part of it,
I guess it maybe it was an episode.
It was called the guerrilla war.
So we're going to take a look at that.
Also on top of that to expand on some of the topics,
I'm also going to take a look at a book called Vietnam Primer,
and it's,
it's a pretty cool book.
It's very tactical and when I say tactical,
I'm not talking about,
I'm talking actual tactical like it shows where you should put your security
elements while you're in Vietnam.
What's the best way to maneuver through the jungle in Vietnam?
It's very,
very specific to that kind of jungle fighting,
but there are definitely some topics in it that I wanted to pull out and that is
the book in about face when Hackworth is talking about working with Sla
Marshall,
which we covered his book on one 42 he's talking about how we work with them and
they wrote when they got done with going in interviewing all these people,
they wrote the book Vietnam Primer and so I wanted to at least take a look at
that.
I probably won't cover it in any great depth on the podcast because it's so
tactical and it's very specific to that time and yeah,
maybe I'll cover it someday but cause you never know.
Well anyways,
there's definitely some things to get out of it that I want to look at and we'll
pull some of those up today.
But the basis is to look at this,
this interview with Hackworth and I think you're going to see it.
It takes a lot of stuff from about face and just really puts it in the clear cut
in the clear.
So here we go.
People,
century guerrilla,
guerrilla wars.
And this is the interview with David Hackworth from PBS.
What do you think the Viet Cong learn learned from mount?
Say Tone and Hackworth says,
I think the major thing was how a poor man fights a rich man.
How a war can be fought employing ancient rules,
first developed by Sun Tzu.
The need for patients,
the need for political motivation,
the need to fight a war of economy and how to employ all the rules of warfare.
So there you go.
That's a little way to start this thing off the need for patients.
The need for political motivation.
And he gets,
he gets into this and he talks a lot about,
talks a lot about the economy because that's something that you can lose track
of as a front line person.
But you need to think about it.
Uh,
next.
This is,
this is very interesting.
What lessons should the Americans have learned from the French defeat?
So the French got beaten Vietnam.
And here's what Hackworth says.
Well,
I think the major lesson they should have learned was that that war didn't
involve the security of France and the security of the United States.
It wasn't an issue either on a tactical level.
They didn't have an objective.
They didn't have an objective on a tactical lover.
So clearly the point is you have to have an objective.
He goes on.
The Americans should have studied the lessons of the French very closely and
taken something from them.
A correspondent once asked a general Westmoreland,
the American commanding general and architect of the war,
what he thought of how the French fought the war and was he studying the lessons
of the French.
He said,
why should I study the lessons of the French?
They haven't won a war since Napoleon.
This was the attitude of American total arrogance.
We didn't learn from the past.
We didn't learn from our own experience by going back to when we beat Britain in
1776 at that time,
the British had argued that we didn't fight in formation such as there's a big
block formation.
We didn't meet them in the open and fought and we fought like the Indians behind
trees using concealment and cover and so on.
And a couple of hundred years later,
we had the British mentality towards fighting and we had forgotten the lessons
that we had taught the British.
That stinks,
doesn't it?
When that ego gets out of control,
you know,
can you think about the thing about that,
that quote from Westmoreland is awful.
Why should I study the lessons?
The French,
they hadn't won a war since Napoleon.
That's,
that's,
that's awful to read.
That is why.
That is why the,
the seals that when I was running training the seals that would get fired,
the leader,
the seals that would get fired for leadership problems or from leadership
positions,
they would be getting fired because of that attitude right there.
They don't listen to anybody.
And,
and what's interesting about this Hackworth is actually saying the lose,
you should actually even listened to the loser.
Hmm.
Put that ego in check.
Next question.
Don't think that the United States tremendous fire power could have won the war.
Okay.
Hackworth.
The war could never have been one.
In terms of the employment of firepower,
the solution to winning the war was to cause reform in the government to win the
hearts and minds of the people to make the cause justifiable so that the people
of the country,
we're willing to give up their lives.
This was not done.
You could have used all the fire power in the world.
All the technical ability that the US had to fight the enemy and you'd have
maybe one a temporary tactical respites that's,
that's important because you know something.
Sometimes you think yourself,
well if we just,
if we put enough bombs on them,
yeah,
well we can shut them down.
I mean short of nuking them.
But I think that's important.
He's saying you could maybe possibly win.
Cause I,
I think ourself,
yeah.
I mean if you've dropped enough bombs on people,
you know,
you can,
you can shut him down.
But he's saying you can,
you can win a tactical,
a temporary tactical respites
back to the interview.
But we'd never won a war strategically unless we had people had the people join
our side.
We'd,
I'm going to read that again,
but we'd never have won the war strategically unless we had the people on our
side.
The war was about the people and winning over their hearts and their minds and
their allegiance to the host country.
The host country in Vietnam was made up of gangsters.
Next question,
but you weren't there as a soldier to win hearts and minds.
You were there strictly for military purposes,
Hackworth.
If you were a student of warfare,
if you were a student of warfare,
as I was,
you quickly realized that tactically we were not going to win the war and we had
to win the people.
And this is basically the same conclusion.
You know when I,
when I got to Iraq the second time and I saw the Intel reports and,
and saw that what we were doing was the capture kill missions and,
and I saw that they had as many targets.
They are always in Iraq,
2003 2004 and they had as many targets up on the wall in 2006 when I got back as
they had,
when I left.
So that to me,
he said,
this is just the,
when is this?
Are we,
is this ever gonna stop?
It didn't look like it to me.
We had to do something different and that's when I read the counterinsurgency
manual my second day on deployment or something like that and,
and figured out what he was saying right there.
He had it.
You had to take care of the people.
Next question.
So we're the efforts to resettle whole villages of Vietnamese a good way to
fight this war,
Hackworth?
No,
because the Americans,
again,
tried to impose their values on the country of Vietnam without understanding the
culture and the religion of Vietnam.
It was a country made up of who were shipped ancestors frequently listen to
this,
frequently,
people who had been moved from their homes would go through minefields to get
back to worship at the graves of their ancestors.
We didn't understand that.
We didn't understand what the Vietnamese culture was all about.
Okay.
So imagine that you just think you can just,
you think you're just move people around.
Yeah,
no,
actually you can't do that.
That that ground is holy to them.
That grant is where their family is.
They have deep rooted ties and we didn't recognize that.
Next question.
What do you think was so particularly good about the Vietcong guerrilla
fighters?
What did you as a military man respect about them?
Most Hackworth,
I respected their dedication.
The fire in their belly.
They're great.
Strong belief in freedom.
Yeah.
So that's interesting because of course we're looking at them,
we're looking at the Vietnamese thinking,
they're communist and there
we think we're fighting for our freedom.
Yeah.
Right.
But,
and this is other,
this is
a fairly common opinion about Vietnam,
is that they just didn't want outsiders,
like they saw any outsiders.
We're,
we're imposing on their freedom.
So even if we were going to bring glorious democracy,
it wasn't their glorious democracy.
They didn't want it.
Yeah.
Back to the interview,
there's was a mission,
a complete dedication to winning independence for their country.
So there you have it.
So I respected them for,
for where they were coming from.
Maybe it was empathy.
My ancestors two or 300 years ago had fought for the British,
or sorry,
had fought the British.
What about their strategy and tactics?
Hackworth as fighters,
they were very fanatical and very dedicated.
They were like my paratroopers who were extraordinarily fine soldiers.
A soldier tends to respect a counterpart that's a heavyweight and they were
indeed heavyweights because of their devotion to the cause.
Okay,
next question.
A female gorilla leader said that sometimes when they shot in American soldier,
his comrades would come up to get the body and then they'd all burst into tears,
which she said was a wonderful opportunity to shoot them or to grab their
weapons.
Is that a fair comment,
Hackworth?
It's right on the mark.
The problem with Americans fighting that war was that as the war went on,
they lost leadership.
They lost their hardcore professional leaders.
A professional soldier does not go after wounded.
He leaves that to the medics,
but soldiers that are not well trained and not well disciplined by their leaders
tend to become more of a group of fraternity buddies who care very much for
their fallen comrade and who want to get him out of the line of fire.
In Vietnam,
it was known that the standard technique to use was to hit the first guy,
then take out anybody going after him.
That was how they'd add to their casualty list.
I've had my soldiers tell me that a guy might have been hit in the leg in a hot
fire fight,
and his opponent,
Omi 10 or 15 feet away,
would be pointing at pointing his weapon at him,
giving him the finger,
doing all these things to tease him while he's waiting for someone to come out
and pull them away.
Then they could blow that guy away too.
Prioritize and execute.
You've got to know what the most important problem you've got,
and it's not the wounded guy,
it's the guy that's trying to kill you
and you gotta be able to,
you got to train your guys to be able to overcome that emotional situation that
they're going through because that's going to be the instinct.
That's the human instinct.
Next question.
The Vietcong hid in the jungle,
but in the Mekong Delta there really isn't any jungle.
So where did the Vietcong hide?
I like this answer,
Hackworth.
Well,
they were hidden in the jungle.
That was always alongside the waterways,
which tended to be very thick and weld booby trapped out in front.
They were hidden by the people they hid in the waterways.
They would get underwater and take a read and put it above the water and breathe
through that.
Then surround themselves with a bit of floating Nepa grass.
They would dig caves under the waterways and then put a bit of read up to the
top and breathe through that.
They were very,
very cunning fighters.
Yeah,
that's,
that's like what you hear about in the movies,
right?
The little read breathing through.
Read and they actually doing that and he goes into that more here.
Next question.
Did you have any personal experience of finding Vietcong lurking under the water
surface Hackworth?
Oh,
commonly if we saw a bit of Nepa floating down a waterway,
a bit of jungle debris,
we fired out it in,
invariably it would turn red.
That meant there was that below was a Viet cong hanging onto the roots of the
debris with a read going up to get air and we'd killed one enemy.
Once we located them,
I always took concertina wire and put it on both sides of the creek so they
couldn't float down.
They'd run into the wire.
I instructed my soldiers to fire it,
any foliage,
and in most cases there would be a Viet cong hanging on trying to get out.
They were simply the most skillful,
the most dedicated,
the best opponent of struck,
you know,
almost 50 years of being around soldiers.
They're the best
question.
What other problems were unique in the Mekong Delta?
The problem in the Delta was not only the terrible conditions that prevailed
there,
but it was the impact it had.
On your soldiers.
I'm speaking now as an American.
We had terrible casualties from what we called immersion foot.
Immersion foot was the problem in world war one called trench foot.
After being in the water for a long time,
the feet would become very soft and the boot rubbing against the foot.
We become very abrasive.
Suddenly you've had it.
You'd have a hole in your foot the size of a bullet hole and suddenly you're a
lost soldier.
Okay.
We had to be,
you had to be very wary and take care of the feet.
There was no place to sleep,
so you were in the water at night.
Your soldiers were in the water and you stayed miserable and wet.
My rule was that a unit could only stay in the field for five days.
After five days of immersion foot set in so badly that a whole battalion of 800
men could be laid up for weeks.
I got immersion foot one time.
Yeah,
I got legit immersion foot and so I was doing a training exercise in,
it was added.
It was,
we were doing a training exercise,
doing a reconnaissance of an air field that was located around the swamp.
So I spent five or six days in this swamp and not the whole five or six days,
but,
uh,
a good amount of days.
And plus the days I wasn't in the swamp,
there was heavy rain,
so just my feet were wet for an extended period of time.
Actually on this particular training exercise when we were going into the field,
it was raining when we got in the field that started sleeping,
you know,
like,
like ice and that turned to snow.
And so it was right around,
you know,
and then in the day time it warmed up and it will turn back to rain.
But it was a pretty miserable six days.
But when I got out of the field and,
and quite frankly,
I didn't really understand the threat of immersion foot.
So I just kept my boots on probably almost the whole time.
And when I got out of my feet were really jacked up,
really jacked up.
I,
as a matter of fact,
I was looking at some pictures just to see how bad I had it compared to how bad
it can get.
I just looked at some pictures on,
you know,
on the Inter webs and my feet were jacked up.
Legit wa I mean obviously this is,
I mean I've never heard immersion foot,
but that's a common for the trench foot,
right?
Yeah.
So that's common knowledge,
right?
Yeah.
Cause remember Forrest Gump when he said that,
when he's like,
uh,
Lieutenant Dan,
when you met up with her coming to tell you things or whatever,
and one of them was keep your socks dry.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So that's definitely a common thing.
But he's,
he talks about it a lot.
You've got to,
you got to inspect guy's feet,
make sure their feet are good to go.
Yeah.
When guys feet aren't good to go,
they're done.
You can't walk,
you're done.
But my feet from that immersion foot,
they were numb.
They were numb like dead.
What?
Cause it got cold or were it was the,
it was house is just the wetness.
Yeah.
Well,
it was cold.
It only snowed and it only was below freezing that first night.
And then it was a warmer,
but they were wet for a long time.
Yeah.
That was when I was young.
And then when you take it really dumb,
take off your shoes,
does it like does the pain set in the end or no,
they were actually,
they went there.
They went.
Who didn't hurt at all?
They did but they didn't hurt.
They hurt more when I got out of the field.
That's when they started to hurt.
Yeah,
they were actually numb.
because I mean the way I imagined it is like,
you know how I don't know you're in the pool or the bath or you know when you're
a kid you in the bathroom like super and your following it all love uncle.
Yeah.
Prunes or whatever.
The prunes pruned up fee.
But as I think that times five days going like too far.
Yeah they,
cause they seem kind of sensitive to when you think about it,
you know,
like all that kind of sensitive.
So
next,
next question.
Why were you mad in the water?
Why didn't they walk along the banks or along pathways between patty fields,
Hackworth.
You could expect any dry surface was mined to booby trapped and 60% of all
casualties we had in Vietnam came from mines and booby traps laid.
I might add by those local gorillas who the generals at the top Westmoreland and
assistance didn't count.
So he's saying the local gorillas,
they talk about how the,
the the generals like Westmoreland would say,
Oh,
you know,
there's this many people and they wouldn't count the local populous or these
local gorillas as insurgents
continuing.
They didn't believe that they were the enemy because their mentality was a world
war two mentality.
They didn't understand the nature of the war.
They were re fighting World War Two and they thought they could win the war by
applying heavy fire power.
The outpourings of Detroit and great technological ability.
They thought they would steam roll this opponent into defeat.
They found that a war could not be won with bulldozers against somebody fighting
with great cause.
Next question,
but after the Tet offensive didn't the heavy bombing raids actually take a very
heavy toll on the Vietcong Hackworth?
Well,
General Lemay said,
if I had enough bombs,
I could win this war because I'd blast the Vietnamese back to the stone age.
What he didn't understand was that the Vietnamese were already living in the
stone age and that firepower wouldn't work under those circumstances.
I do think you're correct that at the end of Tet 1968 February,
1968 we increased the amount of bomb tonage out of frustration Vietnam as a
country about the size of California in terms of area.
We used three times the amount of bombs and the Vietnam war as we did in all of
world two,
both the allies and the axis.
How's that for just completely insane.
We put enough steel on that California size target to sync it and it did not
cause the opponent to give in fire.
Power was not the answer.
The answer was to win the hearts and minds of the people.
Question,
why didn't fire power work Hackworth?
Well,
what firepower did using pursuit aircraft fighter aircraft,
fighter bombers,
artillery,
mortar,
and so on.
What it did was it galvanized the opponent.
It puts steel in their back.
They could see themselves being struck by a giant and they had no way,
no recourse to strike back it as it did historically with the British in World
War II.
It put fire in their belly.
It was absolutely the worst thing we could do in Vietnam.
It gave them a tonic to fight harder.
So we've covered that on the podcast about how the Brits,
when the Brits got bombed,
psychologically it made them tougher because there's something happening.
This,
this massive attack comes will,
it seems like a massive attack.
It's something you can't control,
something you can't fight back.
But when you bomb a city of a million people,
there's actually a small number of that get that actually get impacted by it.
So everyone else goes,
hey,
we can survive this.
And so that's what happened with the Vietnamese.
They are,
you drop these giant bombs on us.
Guess what?
I'm still here.
Yeah,
you can't do anything to me.
America,
Big America.
With your big bombs.
I'm still,
I'm still right here.
What do you got?
Hm hmm.
Now I'll tell you what if the recent fighting in,
in Iraq against Isis,
there's been a lot of bombing in the bombing has been,
let's just say it was a very,
very productive,
very,
very productive and,
and they killed a lot,
a lot,
thousands and tens of thousands of,
of Isis fighters.
And even with that being said,
there was ground forces that had to move in.
But man,
they did it.
A lot of devastating,
devastating destruction of the Emmy with that stuff.
So I think in certain situations you can have a massive impact with firepower.
Yeah.
But isn't that like,
like you said,
like isn't that like because of intelligence that they had and stuff like that,
there was more more to it than just hey,
let's just,
yeah,
I'm sure a bunch of [inaudible] and the Isis were easier targets and not like
not only easier targets but better weapon tree.
Cause man,
if you look at the number,
like I remember reading something about a bridge that they were trying to take
out in Vietnam and they been launched mission after mission after mission after
mission.
Him dropped bomb after bomb after Irma.
It's hard.
It was hard back then to to actually hit something like a bridge.
Gotcha.
Okay.
You know what I'm saying?
We'll have to get,
we'll have to get Dave Burke on here.
Good.
Tilty yeah,
good deal Dave.
We'll have to get him on here and,
and talk about how hard
that is too with dumb bombs.
Cause you know what?
Everyone says smart bombs.
Now those were down bombs.
You had to basically you've got to eyeball it and I call a mistake.
Can you imagine how hard that is?
Like okay,
we get that.
If you just want to bomb this general,
this city,
right?
You can just drop bombs on the city.
Okay,
I get you can hit that,
but you're trying to hit a bridge.
Can you imagine how hard that's got to be?
Yeah,
I do.
Because I used to play this game called Mario Kart.
Right?
So it's like a split split screen and it's the track and you get these weapons,
right and you're playing your friend who's sitting right next to you cause it's
a split screen and you can pick up these weapons.
So two of the weapons where the turtle Shell is the red one and a green one.
The red one was a smart turtle shell it like seek the other guy out.
But the green one just went in the exact direction that you shut it.
So imagine you're on a track,
you're taking turns just way harder with a green shell,
you know.
So back in Vietnam was the green shell.
Nowadays we've got the red shoe.
You pretty much fully understand this flu.
It's the same
check.
All right.
With that,
we'll go back to the interview.
Next question.
When you were active in the Mekong Delta,
was it difficult to tell who was Viet Cong and who was civilian Hackworth?
I was in the ninth division and our commander was General Julian [inaudible] who
was called the butcher of the delta.
The policy of the division was that it didn't matter if it moved,
shoot it.
And then count it.
Theoretically,
civilians were supposed to be away from the battle area.
They would say this as they would say this is a free fire zone,
but without realizing the tradition of the people to go back to their homestead.
So regardless of the danger,
they would go back to where their ancestors were and then they were considered
Vietcong and fair game.
There were an enormous number of casualties who were civilians,
but all the civilians you have to understand we're sympathetic.
Certainly in my part of the delta to the Vietcong effort,
most of the people in the rural areas of Vietnam were sympathetic to the Viet
Cong cause they had won the hearts and minds of the Vietnamese people.
They felt that their cause was more just,
it had a more nationalistic purpose
question.
You will once flying in a helicopter over the Delta and you saw some people
running along and you fought their civilians,
they're children Hackworth.
Yes.
One day we were doing what's called Eagle flies,
which is a platoon of infantry helicopters,
five,
six soldiers per helicopter and I was controlling everything in a command and
control helicopter.
The pilot in the front seat of my helicopter said that there are four enemies
streaking across the field request permission to fire as commander.
I would grant that permission.
I looked down and I saw four little kids,
so I said negative.
Those are little kids.
They're just playing hooky from school or something.
Leave them alone,
and I went ahead and inserted my platoon and let them maneuver through area.
Suddenly they took fire from those poor little kids who were probably no more
than 12 or 13 years old and it stashed there.
Ak 47 so I was wrong.
My previous experience had been up in the highlands.
That was one of my first days in the delta and I was learning that just about
anybody in that battlefield.
Sadly enough was a hostel
question.
Were they ever helpful to you?
Hackworth?
Again,
he hits it here.
60% of all casualties,
60% of all US casualties during that war for from mines and booby traps that
were set out by these local people who had built them and installed them.
Ironically enough,
the top generals never counted those people as part of the enemy's order of
battle.
Even though they accounted for about 300,000 people,
they were conveniently dropped from the rolls.
They were only counted when they were found dead going into any battle area.
If we picked up a civilian,
he became our point man against the Geneva Convention.
The assumption was that if this cat lived here,
he knew how to get through this area without losing a leg or a life.
He could lead our forces through.
So that's,
again,
we've covered this a bunch,
but the local populace,
there's,
they're walking through these triple down these trails every single day,
and they're not hitting any booby traps.
And then you lose a guy today,
you lose a guy tomorrow.
Eventually you realize that they add a minimum.
They know where these booby traps are at Hackworth saying there,
they're the ones that set them up,
made them,
and set them up.
Oh yeah.
So it mentioned against the Geneva Convention to grab a civilian.
So they're,
they're sort of grabbing them in what?
Forcing them it.
Like,
Hey,
you're going to walk.
Yeah.
Like you're going to walk out in front.
You're going to take us through this.
This trail.
Like a Husky.
Yeah.
Almost like a hostage of source.
Next question.
What was a simple booby trap?
Well,
the Punji stake was a no brainer.
Normally they were set in a position where they would strike your ankle.
It would scratch you.
You are in filthy water.
You'd get an infection.
I had a pungy wounded and I didn't know it.
I must have got it in the morning and it bled a lot.
I didn't know until I got out of the water and looked at my boot and it was
soaking read from blood.
There was a wound that looked very much like as if someone had taken a razor and
made about a three inch long slash in my leg,
it became infected.
That was the problem.
It wasn't a long term wound.
It was something that put you down for a few days.
It had to be cleaned out,
debrided than it would be stitched up and you were fine.
The real killer was the coffee can filled with explosives from a dud,
American round.
Everything they used,
we gave them,
we threw away our c ration cans.
We threw away our used batteries.
We through where coffee cans.
If a 500 pound bomb didn't explode,
that provided them with a raw materials for their booby traps,
so they set up their booby trap factory.
They opened up the mine.
They took out the explosives,
packed it in a can wrapped barbed wire and nails and other things around it.
Got a primer device from a grenade that was left behind,
put a trip wire on it and set it on the side of the road.
When the first soldier hit it,
he would lose his life and maybe three or four people behind them would be down.
I've seen what we call number 10 cans.
The large cans packed full of [inaudible] and so filled with nails to have a
fragment effect that it could take down 10 or 12 people.
The impact on the soldier was a psychological impact that every time you put
your foot down,
you didn't know whether you're going to have a leg or a limb or a life.
Then this played over and over for 365 days of going down trails,
going down waterways.
It took the fight out of you.
I took over the battalion down at the delta.
It was called the hard luck battalion in six months before I took it over.
It had 600 casualties,
killed and wounded all from mines and booby traps.
It had never met the enemy.
It was all from these insidious little devices put down by these people that the
generals didn't count because they didn't understand the nature of the war.
Yeah,
and I think,
I think the numbers for Iraq was 75% of the casualties or from IED.
Yeah,
75% off to confirm that,
but whatever it was,
it's a huge number.
It's a huge number.
It must be an odd feeling to find that,
you know,
like Dang.
They meet that bomb out of our stuff.
Like,
especially at first when he used to it.
It's different like you're like,
what if you came across the results of Obama and it's like,
Dang,
I was just using that coffee can,
you know,
like two days ago or something like that.
Well,
yeah,
that's why disciplined soldiers wouldn't leave anything behind ever.
Yeah.
But lack of disciplined soldiers would leave all the stuff behind.
Now sometimes you drop bombs and they don't detonate.
That's so they can't really fault anyone for that.
But yeah,
coffee cans and they,
they,
they taught us when,
when I,
when I was going through training,
they taught us like we weren't allowed to leave anything behind.
Couldn't leave anything behind because we didn't want the enemy to use it.
Yeah.
It's a way.
It was.
And you know what the,
you know what the Iraqis,
Iraqis did the same thing.
The insurgents,
I should say the insurgency in Iraq,
they used old ordinance.
Now some of the old ordinance that they used was actually from the old Iraqi
army.
A lot of it,
but a lot of it was from unexploded ordinance,
just like what the Vietnam Viet Cong used.
Yeah.
And even to me it kind of seemed like even if it wasn't stuff to use,
like,
I mean man,
it's a
spectrum.
Like some,
you know how like when you know,
in the movie where the crib,
the crib and all,
they're chasing the criminal with the dogs in the criminal left part of his
shirt or something,
and then the dog sort of smells it.
It's like that feeling like your enemy has like something in yours,
right?
So he on one side of the spectrum is like,
okay,
they use it to make bombs,
right.
Which is kind of just maybe psychologically just kind of odd.
And then just the fact that for example,
like what if in Iraq you capture somebody or whatever and he has like a pair of
like some old army boots or something.
For sure buddy.
Well,
I'd say,
yeah,
that's,
that's uh,
I see it hitting you.
I'm trying to figure out why this is kind of shocking to you.
And it must be the first time you've ever thought about this.
Yeah.
So for me,
yeah,
like for instance,
this was horrible.
So just think about this.
There was an element of snipers that got overrun in Ramadi.
Hmm.
And so think about what the enemy got.
Sniper weapons night vision.
God's always like you're horrified.
Night Vision goggles and sniper weapons so that it takes what you were just
talking about and multiplies it times a lot.
He's now the enemy has legitimate equipment that puts them a little bit higher
on the,
on the tactical level.
So that's definitely scary and that's why we're so careful about never leaving
anything behind.
Yeah.
Next question.
What did these sorts of casualties due to the morale of a more of American
soldiers?
Hackworth just blew it away.
Just like a mine blew away a leg.
It just played with your mind.
Months after I left Vietnam,
I found myself walking across an open field and I suddenly said,
where am I?
And froze in my mind,
I was in a minefield.
It took a few minutes for me to work out that I was not in a minefield.
I believe that a lot of the so called Vietnam Stress Syndrome that has created
so many walking wounded across America today is due to the damage caused long
ago by what they saw of their mates going down by mines and booby traps.
Remember of the 60,000 dead in 300,000 Americans wound in that war,
60% were from mines and booby traps.
He driving that point home.
The great irony was that the infancy stroller infantry soldiers who went to
Vietnam received a total of five hours of training in mines and booby traps.
That was the curriculum used in World War II.
We simply didn't learn.
Yeah,
I can tell you they turned up by,
I mean,
when I was running training,
but we went crazy with IED,
like our,
our fake ids.
But yeah,
we would get nuts with them.
We put them all over the place and just,
you had to,
you had to figure it out.
What yet?
You had to be careful.
Yeah,
but I'll tell you man,
it is hard when someone's good at making those ids and camouflaging him.
Scary.
Yeah.
We'd have to like brief the training cadre over and over again to make sure the
training college,
I didn't set off the ids then we would be building
next.
What was the purpose of the Viet Cong tunnels in the sort of Coochie area north
of Saigon,
Hackworth,
the purpose of the tunnels to provide safe areas for supplies for their
headquarters and for their soldiers.
A great casualty producer for them was artillery air bombing and machine guns
strikes from aircraft and helicopters.
Most of the tunnels were located in areas that had great limestone formations.
It was easy to dig in,
but still quite strong and easy to shore up.
They could go down to three,
four actual floors with pumped in air and brought in water.
It gave them a secure area that was really behind the American lines and the
Americans never really worked out that they were there.
For example,
there was a place called the iron triangle.
There was a great number of such tunnels and a general named Williamson.
Took a brigade in there and said,
the iron triangle is no more.
That was in 1965 at the beginning of the American involvement in the war when
the north seas,
the country and they win.
When they won the war in 1975 their headquarters was in the iron triangle in
those very caves.
That's,
that's like another situation.
You call this area secure and the enemy has actually has their headquarters
there.
Crazy.
Next question.
Wasn't it possible to block up the tunnels or gas them or blow them up?
Hackworth?
We try to,
everything possible to destroy the tunnels,
including having small soldiers called tunnel rats go down and try and clear
them,
but they were so cleverly done,
you can never find where the actual end was.
There would be a dead end with a hidden door going down to the next level.
I'm sure that if enough creativity and effort had gone into it,
then yes,
they could have been closed up,
but the top generals were not concerned.
And Anecdote,
a cave expert came to me between my tours in Vietnam and my office in the
Pentagon.
He said,
look,
I can help you win the war.
I can tell you where the caves are because this is something I've studied my
whole life.
I took him to my boss,
a Vietnam veteran who is very excited about it.
We took them to our general and he didn't want to know about it.
Who wants to waste money?
Sending this guy over there and have them examine tunnels and caves?
What's he going to tell us?
Again,
it was the mentality that firepower will win the war,
these great outpourings of American industrial strength.
We'll win this war.
This arrogance didn't allow us to get beyond a blinkered military mindset.
Good advice for life and this,
this is something that w with echelon front working with a lot of businesses,
sometimes your strategy is wrong and it was,
it wasn't the,
that's what happened in Iraq with us.
Your strategy was not working and it took us time to figure that
out and start doing a counterinsurgency campaign,
but I see this with businesses a lot too.
They're using some strategy and it's not working,
but maybe they used it 12 years ago.
Maybe they used it two years ago and it worked and,
and they were celebrated and now they're just going to do it harder.
Do the same strategy more.
Seems like that's the case with marketing.
You know,
marketing just changes so much.
like when you're marketed to the new strategy that it's not as obvious,
but the old strategies,
you know,
like door to door salesman,
oh yeah.
Door to door salesman comes into your house now,
Bro,
you don't want to hear it.
But why did you even come to my house?
Well that's like,
wouldn't that be considered just a complete waste?
Cause you gotta Pay Some Kid,
whatever,
12 bucks an hour to go door to door,
whereas you can pay 12 bucks and send out a,
I don't know,
email or something.
Yeah.
But even emails.
That's what's the new deal.
I Dunno.
Facebook ads know even that's kind of old now.
But,
um,
no,
door to door there was a time were door to door was dope.
You know,
it's funny,
as I still talk to people that will go out and make stuff happen door to door.
So now it's old school again.
Right?
The old schools coming back,
here's the thing,
usually door to door,
it seems like a hard sell.
So He sure they'll make things happen,
but it's not as efficient as other ways.
Like newer ways of marketing.
And these people come to my house,
door to door people.
They want to sell me stuff.
Yeah.
How many times have you bought zero.
So that's the point I'm trying to,
I'm like running through my mind to see if,
if that was unsolid answer,
I'm actually,
I'm actually pretty sure that in the last 20 years I bought zero from door to
door salesman.
Right.
But,
and when,
and that's probably common where,
I mean consider the feeling you have when someone comes to you.
So there's some people that make money obviously.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And I'm not saying no one has seen these.
I've worked with some companies where they do door to door sales,
but he got song,
good sales kits.
They're selling a good product and they're like,
okay,
we're going to get this out there.
Right?
So think on doors,
dig it.
But there was a time back in the day when Dora Dora was kind of the dope thing.
It's like,
Hey,
and when you think about it,
it would make sense because door to door,
like back long time ago,
I remember people used to come over,
they just knocked on the door.
There wasn't cell phone or nothing like that.
If there were super courteous,
they call before they came,
but if that's your neighbor,
your friend or whatever,
people would knock on your door all the time.
Now people don't just show up at your door.
It's cool because they're lazy also.
I'm sorry the text.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying so,
but back in the day,
door to door salesmen,
they were put it this way,
they weren't as unwelcome as they are now as a work.
There was more random people showing up at your house.
There's a bunch of reasons as what I'm saying,
but the point is back in the day that marketing technique or that sales
technique or whatever was was more effective than it is now.
I'm not saying it's a zero effective.
Not saying is way more,
you know,
because things change.
So if you're a company and you're like,
hey,
I think door to door is the,
is the the way to go because
back in,
you know,
75 and we were killing,
kind of thing.
Well that was what's interesting.
So going back to Iraq and going away from door to door sales here for a moment,
that was what's interesting about the surge,
what was the surge was not just more people,
it was new strategy,
it was more counterinsurgency focused strategy.
And luckily that we shifted that strategy because it wasn't going well up until
that point.
Next question.
But these tunnels were militarily significant workday Hackworth.
They were running sore from the beginning to the end and they were a very
powerful ally of the Vietcong question.
You were in the states at the time it happened,
but do you remember hearing about the Tet offensive in 1968 Hackworth when the
tet offensive occurred in 1968 I was in the Pentagon.
A dear friend of mine was an aide to a very senior general,
so he was privy to a lot of information that we Indians didn't have,
meaning the lower ranking guys as opposed to the chief's Indians.
He came and whispered in my ear and he told me about the attack long before
hours,
before anyone in the press or public knew anything about it.
I was quite frankly shocked and heartbroken.
I had been convinced for two years at the Viet Cong were going to win the war,
that the Americans simply didn't understand the nature of the war.
It was very much epitomized.
When Walter Cronkite ask the American people,
what the Hell is going on here?
I thought we were winning the war.
That was the kind of shock it was to the American people.
Everyone had been fed these glowing after action reports by the president Lyndon
Johnson by General Westmoreland,
that there was light at the end of the tunnel,
that we were prevailing,
that it would only be a matter of months.
The American public was still oriented towards World War Two.
They were believing that as long as we grab this real estate,
we would eventually find the light at the end of the tunnel.
But the light at the end of the tunnel was a Viet cong freight train coming on
full bore.
That's what we discovered in Tet of 1968 and that was the turning point of the
war.
The question,
why was it the turning point Hackworth tat was a turning point because it
destroyed the will of the American people to support the war.
Both soldiers who were in the know realized that this was just the beginning of
the end.
We saw that the American people switched off.
If the support of the people is not there,
you are going to be caught off at the legs.
And that's exactly what happened in Vietnam.
And this is when I was on that show,
on the history channel,
the warriors show,
and I talked about how you had to have the will to kill and the will to die and
to show about Mark Lee.
And that's,
that's where that quote that I,
that statement that I made is rooted in what I learned from Acworth.
That is you have to have this will,
you have to have the will and the people.
The nation has to have the will.
It's not just the military has to have the,
well yeah,
it's the people.
Cause what is,
what is the military?
The military is the people.
Back to the interview,
there had been a fair amount of support for the war until tet of 1968 people
thought it would be unpatriotic not to hang in there and wait until we grab a
noise.
When we,
when the people saw Vietcong climbing on the top of the American embassy,
they knew that they'd been lied to and they knew that this war was not winnable.
All they had to do is ask their sons.
By that time,
I'm probably a million Americans had served in Vietnam and he'd come back home
and told their parents and loved ones the truth about the war.
The government couldn't just provide it with a Madison Avenue snow job.
Anymore
question.
Could the war have been one?
Yeah.
Could the Viet cong had been beaten Hackworth.
The war could not have been one unless the host country,
the Saigon government,
the South Vietnamese changed.
They're very repressive form of government and won the hearts and minds of the
people.
Okay.
They're,
the northern government had employed this technique and they'd created the
promise of this Utopian dream.
As soon as they kicked out the invader,
this repressive south Vietnamese government,
the South Vietnamese government never understood why,
what never understood that they had to make those changes.
Okay.
They were led by greedy people who were into making money.
They had no contact with the people in the main,
they were mainly Catholics and they were into they and they were trying to rule
a country that was 90% Buddhist
question.
Why was body counts so important or was it Hackworth?
Mcnamara was a number cruncher and he wanted to have something to crunch a
number.
The overall strategy was attrition to wear out the enemy by counting bodies.
We would know the impact of the war.
It's success or failure.
That became the standard measurement of success.
It was the score and everyone wanted to know the score.
What really happened was the body count counting completely eroded the honor
code of the military,
specifically among the officer corps,
a top people to lie,
the young fresh lieutenants out of the military academies,
we're taught to lie.
The generals who were pretty proficient liars anyway,
push the body count.
A high body count meant great success,
so in every battle enemy bodies were counted several times.
If there were 200 bodies,
suddenly the figure became 650 and it became to court with Westmoreland,
another great American victory.
It corrupted the officer corps and appalled the soldiers who by that time were
mostly draftees.
They were scurrying around jungle counting bodies,
which was a pretty awesome and terrible thing to do.
It had a real boomerang effect on the military because it was like a cancer.
It destroyed its soul.
Yeah.
What was the military strategy of the war?
Hackworth?
Westmoreland's idea was to destroy the enemies large battle formations as in
World War Two when you've worn the enemy down,
you've won on the field of battle.
That tells you that we simply didn't understand the nature of the war because
the gorilla was not going to fight in that way.
The guerrillas manner of fighting was to hit and run so he could be alive to
fight another day.
You wasn't into these huge standup battles.
Big operations required a great number of resources,
a great amount of logistics,
a great amount of aircraft,
and a greater amount of artillery fire.
Yeah.
Most Diane,
who is the chief of staff of these,
of the Israeli army,
came to Vietnam and I interviewed him right after he had spent two weeks with an
American rifle company of about a hundred men.
He said that in one battle with the North Vietnamese force of a couple hundred
men,
they fired more artillery over 25,000 rounds.
Then he had fired in a whole campaign.
Okay.
That was the American way of fighting a war.
It was also terribly expensive.
Each round was $100.
If you fired 10,000 rounds,
you've probably gone through $1 million in one 15 minute fight and you've killed
seven enemy.
When you look at it from a cost basis,
we are paying an enormous amount to kill the enemy and we couldn't sustain that
kind of momentum and that kind of expenditure for a long time.
It was a failed tactic that never should have been used.
We should have used the same roles that Mao was teaching,
that sun suit taught before to break up in smaller elements and fight fire with
fire.
Okay.
Yeah.
You think about that economic,
you pay $1 million to kill
seven enemy soldiers.
That's your,
it's not going to work out well in the long run.
No
question.
Had you been in charge,
how would you have done things differently?
Hackworth.
During my second year in Vietnam,
I commanded a battalion made up of conscripts down in the delta.
It was a battalion with very bad leadership.
It is sustained 600 casualties in the six months before I took over,
morale was low.
They called themselves the heartbreak battalion within 30 days they turned
around.
Of course,
we've covered this on steel,
my soldiers hearts written by Hackworth about this experience and we also
covered it in about face,
which he covers that as well about this experience,
so I'm moving a little bit quicker here.
We fought like gorillas.
We didn't fight in these huge formations.
We broke up and fought in small units of five or seven people.
We fought at night.
We stole the night from the enemy.
We ambushed.
We didn't march in formations and expect to meet an opponent marching in long
form marching and large formations.
We fought him using his very tactics,
his very skills.
We tore a page out of Mao's book.
The proof of the pudding was six months later that the battalion had only lost
25 American soldiers.
It had killed over 2,600 enemy soldiers and there were no Vietcong in the area
of operation.
Those soldiers proudly called themselves the hardcore battalion and they were
hardcore,
but they were simply simple draftees who didn't want to be their
question.
Are you sure that was an accurate about it?
Body count,
Hackworth.
Yeah,
I think that was an accurate body count.
Considering the inflated body count techniques employed by the US military at
the time question wasn't the fight cause it's a little ironic that he talks
about how bad the body count is and then he uses it so he's Kinda getting called
out on that a little bit.
He should have just stuck to the fact that there was no more Viet Cong
operations in that area.
There used to be x amount of an enemy attacks day and now there was zero.
Sorry Hack.
Come on.
Don't worry.
I've got you.
Wasn't the fighting from 72 to 75 more like more like conventional warfare
Hackworth.
It was conventional warfare.
A guerrilla campaign starts with a few people who are dissatisfied.
They throw rocks at the enemy,
they finally kill an enemy soldier and get a rifle.
They get more rifles and they rate an armory and they get more weapons and they
build and build up.
Phase one of a guerrilla campaign is individual sniping,
laying booby traps and low scale conflict type fighting.
The final phase,
the final goal in phase four or five is to move in brigades and divisions and
cores.
In a conventional formation and that's the culmination of the war,
which is interesting to think about when it's like one of those situations where
what made you strong,
you leave behind,
right?
It happens with companies all the time,
you know,
this company starts off,
they're small,
they're nimble,
they can adapt to the market and then over time they get so big they can't
change anymore.
And then some other company that was a startup is now a small and nimble and can
take advantage of the,
the changes in the market.
Same thing happens
unless you pay attention,
unless you keep yourself mobile,
unless you enact decentralized command,
you can prevent it.
You can keep,
if you,
if you start to centralize everything,
what you have to get somewhat more centralized when you grow like that,
like one thing is in the military you say,
well we've got decentralized command.
Well part of that,
part of the reason we have that we can,
we can let people have decentralized command is because we have the discipline
training upfront,
right?
So once a company,
as a company grows,
if you put discipline on them,
you can allow them to still have decentralized command and act very quickly.
You got to have trust in your subordinate leadership for sure to be able to
employ that
next question,
but the actual defeat of the southern government was by the North Vietnamese
regular army that was hardly a Vietcong victory.
Was it Hackworth?
Oh,
I think that the architect of that general tray was a Vietcong,
a southerner.
He was the one that planned it.
There were a number of Vietcong divisions.
For example,
the Ninth Viet Cong division in the delta fought and the final battles as a
regular unit.
Sure,
the majority were regular forces from the north,
but they fought in hit and run type operations.
They always fought on the offensive.
That is interesting to note is that of 100% of all contacts,
when one guy attacks another 85% were enemy initiated.
That means that throughout the war,
the Americans were on the defensive 85% of the time and the enemy,
the Vietcong and the North Vietnamese was on the offensive.
You can't win a war by being on the defense,
you have to have the offensive power.
We didn't have the initiative throughout the war from beginning to end.
The initiative rested in the hands of the opponent,
the Vietcong and the North Vietnamese.
That's like,
um,
in Jujitsu when someone's just attacking and attacking and attacking,
you're defending the whole time you're going down.
I mean,
eventually you're going down to mentally.
And that was something that,
that we definitely changed up in for my last deployment when we were in Ramadi
with task unit bruiser.
Whenever you're on patrol,
you're on defensive,
you're on the defensive.
But once you set up a little Overwatch position and you're waiting for the enemy
patrol and now you're ambushing them.
So now you're on the offense.
So I mean,
we weren't on offense 85% of the time,
but we were on offense a lot of the time.
The boys were getting out on offense and surprising the enemy on a regular
basis.
I mean,
probably more than half the time because we were also doing things where we
definitely,
we were on the defensive.
I mean,
it's authentic and defensive at the same time.
When you're pushing through,
uh,
when you're doing the clearance operation,
you're on offense,
but you're on defense because you're the is waiting for you.
You know?
So there's a little dichotomy and doing that type of mission,
but like doing a direct action mission where you're going to go and take down a
building where you think there's a bad guy.
You're authentic when you get to that target,
but while you're going to the target,
you're waiting to get ambushed.
You're waiting to get ambushed.
That's what you're doing.
Even though you're scanning,
even though you're looking for threats or you're still waiting to get ambushed,
you're waiting to roll over an ID.
So even though you feel like you're on offense and we train our guys to be an
offense,
but the reality is the first shot in those situations is absolutely going to be
fired by the enemy.
The ID is going to be initiated by the enemy.
Once you do the raid,
the raid itself,
that's us being on offense,
right,
right there in their sleeping or they're,
they're not expecting you to come.
And Boom,
you blow their door off and you enter their house and you're on offense.
That's like four minutes.
And so you were saying before that,
before that while you're going to the cause they like protected themselves with
whatever measures unrelated.
Like let's say you're going for a bad guy,
bad guy x and he lives in the house.
You know you're going to get him and when you get there,
you're going to surprise him and he's not gonna be expecting you.
But on the way there,
bad guy,
z bad guy,
m and bad guy f have all set up ambushes on this road.
Not maybe completely disconnected with my ex,
but you are going to have to go through the ambushes that they've set and,
and they don't care.
They'll set up that ambush tonight.
No one comes.
Okay,
cool.
We'll set up tomorrow night.
No one comes to,
we'll set up tomorrow night.
You want to got to go down that one road one time to get ambushed.
So you're on.
So when you're going,
when you're,
when you're moving through enemy territory,
you are on defense.
Yeah.
Again,
that's not the mindset we teach the mindset.
It's like we're on offense where we're going to go get some.
The reality is the first shot is going to be most likely,
most likely fired by the enemy.
Most likely.
That's the way it is and you know we,
we did,
I mean these big clearance bees,
big sector clearance that we were doing,
the army was doing the marine corps to him,
like I said,
you're on offense.
It's an offense at push.
You're making the initiative,
you're taking the initiative and getting in there on a,
on a operational level,
on a tactical level,
most likely the enemy's going to see you first.
They're hidden.
They're hiding the two rooms deep in a building there.
They're waiting and they've got an ID buried in the road,
so so offensive.
It's kind of,
when you think about it is just the like a mindset kind of mainly to begin with
because it's so,
it's like a,
it's like a forward leaning mindset.
I think an offense means you often see is you strike first,
right?
You have the initiative.
That's often when you have the initiative.
That's often when you're reacting,
that's defense.
So like in your situation that you're like,
so if I punch you,
I was on offense,
right?
Yeah.
If you watch me,
I just,
I was on defense.
So yours was like a pump,
you weren't punching.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Yeah,
it's,
it's hard to I guess really get the capture the actual how you would explain
that.
I think the best I could do is what I just said.
Operationally you're on offense meaning we're pushing into your neighborhood.
Yeah.
So that's essentially what it's like this like this,
if you had a,
uh,
a bar,
you are the bouncer at a bar and I had a beef with you.
I showed up at your bar.
Right.
But once I get there and get in your face,
boom,
you crack me.
You just went on offense or even better while I'm going to your bar,
one of your boys steps out of the alleyway.
Cause he was waiting for me.
It cracks me with a bottle in the back of the head.
Right.
I want to be ready for be like you could somehow he got a whole nother thing you
got to contend with.
So there's different orders.
They better kill me
or kill me you and deep into the earth scenario,
feminist Santa's cool.
There it is.
A bit of you
try and be on offense.
Yeah.
That if you,
if you at least the lesson to be learned there for me,
if you're at least think about it,
right.
At least think about that.
You want to be on offense.
And that was what was nice about these,
you know,
a lot of the missions that we did in Iraq,
I was like,
well you were surprising the enemy.
Yeah.
But if you can surprise the enemy,
you're on office.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So like even like here you're looking back to your example,
your,
your missions.
Just the fact that you initiated that capture kill mission,
that's your offensive.
That's offensive movement.
Yeah.
But just like when I'm coming to the bar,
I got to get to the bar,
right.
Defense when we're getting there because I don't know,
I'm going to get hit,
right.
So it's like throwing a punch with that,
with that other hand up.
And it's important to note that we would teach our guys to have an office of
mindset,
meaning when we,
when you saw one of our patrols on one of our vehicle patrols or a foot patrol,
ut every guy ready to engage the enemy.
Yeah,
most likely the first shot's going to come from,
did that happen all the time?
No.
There's sometimes we don't on a patrol guys would engage first or that that
could happen,
but most likely that that's luck.
That's luck.
Because most likely the enemies a little bit smarter.
They're hiding in a,
you know,
when you're walking,
think about when you walked down the street,
they got how many windows there are,
how many doors there are.
So now you just walked down the street and how many windows can you see?
200 300 right?
Yeah.
I mean if you're walking down a city street,
you can see a hundred windows.
Let's say one of those windows could have a bad guy that,
and you can't,
you're not going to see him.
He's going to see first.
Yeah.
So
check next question.
In April of 1975 during the fall of Saigon,
there were some memorable images of American helicopters taking off from the
roof of the American embassy and dozens of south Vietnamese trying to escape.
What were your feelings when you saw those pictures?
Hackworth,
I was heartbroken when I saw the end calm and the helicopters airlifting people
off the embassy.
But at the same time,
in 1971 when I left Vietnam,
I said four years from now the north Vietnamese were fly a flag over this
capital.
The reason I said that,
and I was dead on to the month was that I had been like a doctor feeling the
pulse of a dying patient and it was obvious to me that this patient,
the South Vietnamese government was on its way down.
Question,
was the April,
1975 victory,
a victory for the,
uh,
people's style of war Hackworth.
I think that the victory in Vietnam introduced a new phase of warfare where low
intensity conflict can eventually when questioned what was,
what does the concept of a people's war mean to you?
Hackworth.
It's the same thing that my forefathers employed in 1776 we wanted independence
and we were willing to pay with our lives.
All people want to be free and if they have that anger inside them and the
ability to arm themselves and somebody comes along and says,
Hey,
I'm your leader and I'm going to show you how to do this than the one guy who's
trying to suppress them is in trouble.
Question.
What are the key lessons to be learned from the Viet Cong success?
And actually before we go into that question,
if you think about,
you think about this from a leadership perspective,
we all wanted independence.
We all want to be free.
And if somebody comes along and tries to dictate to you how things are going to
be,
that person's in trouble,
right?
So as the leader,
if you try and impose your will on people,
look,
can you get away with it?
Yes.
Does it work?
If you're the,
you know,
if you can fire someone or yes,
but to be actually lead someone,
you can't just try and impose your will on top of them.
Need to get them in the game too.
Next question.
How important was mass mobilization to the success of the Vietcong Hackworth?
If you're going to fight a war today,
you're going to need your whole nation behind you,
either as fighters or supporters or carriers.
It's no longer the act of a few soldiers fighting on a sunny hill waving swords
at one another.
Warfare is now the employment of the complete population.
The Vietcong took on two south super powers,
France and then the United States,
and they couldn't have done it on a shoe string.
They needed to mobilize everything within their nation and they needed to get as
much outside support as possible.
At the end,
the war became almost a conventional war.
One of the things that bothers me is that the Americans who are now trying to
rewrite history of what actually happened,
say we won all the battles,
but we lost the war,
but we didn't win all the battles.
We lost most of the battles.
This is really,
this is really critical and this is a very important thing to think about.
The reason they've come up with this very bad rationale is because of the
American way of keeping score and the old American way of conventional warfare.
If you're king of the mountain,
at the end of the day,
you've won the battle,
but to the Viet Cong,
it wasn't who held the ground.
It was what kind of punishment you inflicted on your enemy.
The Viet Cong and north Vietnamese were willing to pay an easier,
easy ratio of 10 no one.
If you fought them and you lost one soldier and he lost 10 he walked away
saying,
I was the winner.
There's the mentality that you have to understand and that's why you have to be
willing to kill and you have to be willing to die for going to go to war.
That's why right there.
Hmm.
Question.
Can parallels be drawn between Afghanistan and Vietnam,
between the Vietcong war against the Americans and the mujahideen war success
against the Soviets Hackworth?
Absolutely.
There's no question that the,
that there are sharp parallels between the Afghan war and the war in Vietnam,
the fighters,
there were freedom fighters.
They were trying to rid themselves of communism.
They were supported by an outside country.
This time,
the USA who poured billions of dollars into that war,
they tried to win by using an enormous amount of firepower,
said they being the Russians.
The Russians tried to win by using an enormous amount of firepower,
conventional tactics against the search and destroy operation,
a high degree of technology,
all the mistakes that the Soviets made in Afghanistan,
the Americans made in Vietnam and the French made in Indochina.
Yeah.
No one looked back on the lessons learned.
Hmm.
Did the Soviets learn to anything from America's experience in Vietnam?
Hackworth?
From my analysis of the war,
I'd say very little.
They tried to win the war by using fire power by bombing them back to the stone
age,
through the use of American provided Stinger missiles and by mounting machine
guns in high mountains and firing down on aircraft.
They made the price so heavy for the Soviets have in terms of costs that they
blinked first and got out
okay.
Again,
they used an incredible number of mines and booby traps,
creating a great number of Soviet casualties.
The Soviet units did that did well.
There were special units led by people who understood that form of wealth
warfare,
but their conventional infantry was exactly the same as the American
conventionally infantry in Vietnam or the French conventionally infantry in
Indochina.
Question,
why did the Soviets failed to learn from the American and French mistakes?
Hackworth?
I think it is a military mindset.
We don't want to go back and look at the past.
We're in such a hurry to get where we're going.
There's a certain amount of military arrogance.
The older I get,
the more I realize how we never studied the past and try to learn from it.
We just stumble along and make the same mistakes.
We're doomed to do that until people wake up and with the military mind,
I'm not sure we'll ever wake up.
Got to keep your ego in check.
Got to learn from the past hundred percent correct.
Question.
Is there anything about guerrilla warfare,
which is new to this century?
Yeah,
Hackworth.
Well,
a number of things are new.
The amount of fire power that the insurgent employees and uses the use of booby
traps and minds.
The ability to communicate via electronic communications.
One of the problems that's always hampered the grill is getting the word out.
In the days of old,
it was done by messengers,
which today's an hours today a general has very sharp communications out in
Somalia general,
a deed had little portable radios to talk to his soldiers.
Very low frequency.
The American's CIA's intercept devices are all high frequency.
They couldn't listen to what the man was saying.
They didn't learn a thing.
Question,
how frightened was the average American conscript faced with all these obstacles
and the skill of the enemy
Hackworth,
the average American soldier going into battle in Vietnam carried a whole pack
full of fear,
mainly because he wasn't trained properly back in the states.
The training base was just off.
They were preparing for World War II,
not for insurgency warfare,
so the lad received 16 weeks of training was flung into Vietnam,
generally in a unit that was never kept together,
but it was always filled up by the individual replacement system.
As a result,
there was no real strong cohesion,
no teamwork in the unit,
and this is something that Sla Marshall talked about in men against fire.
The soldier was like an orphan thrown into a family,
but a family that was not solidly put together.
As a result,
his fear level would be high because of the uncertainty of what he was going
into.
The typically,
the typical kid who went to Vietnam was black.
21% of all soldiers were blocked and the Hispanics and the whites were from
others.
The other side of the railroad tracks,
if you went to a good university like Brown university or something,
you'd find you didn't find yourself carrying an m 16 rifle in Vietnam.
You did a Clinton,
you got out of the war.
It was very unfair.
The poor working classes were the ones that carried out the war effort,
but they're made of tough stuff because their whole life required tough stuff.
Once they were provided with the leadership,
the proper leadership,
that raw material did a hell of a job,
but it didn't make the fear go away.
When you're playing in that kind of a lethal super bowl,
the possibility of dying and coming home and a rubber bag is always lingering in
the back of your head.
Regardless of how courageous you are,
you will still have fear,
but if you have competent leadership that you have confidence in and if you're
well trained,
you can get the job done.
It's my theory that the better trained you are,
the more natural courage you have because you have a belief in yourself.
Okay?
That's all important stuff.
The better trained you are,
the more natural courage you have.
Keep that in mind.
Also,
the raw material,
just give me some good leadership and we'll make something happen.
Okay.
Continuing.
Our soldiers weren't well trained and in the main,
they weren't well led,
but the longer the soldiers stayed there,
the more experienced he became and the more confident he became.
The uncertainty was dispelled.
He knew what to expect,
but the fear would never go away.
You know,
you can never go near a battlefield without having those butterflies in your
stomach.
Question,
what frightened your soldiers most?
Hackworth.
I think it was the uncertainty.
Once they got into a unit and knew they were well led,
knew that their commander loved them and cared for them and would not throw them
into harm's way unless absolutely necessary.
Their main fear was just that uncertainty that came from the mines and booby
traps.
Okay,
and it's a psychological thing.
I've walked down trails and I've said to myself,
a sniper has me in his sights.
You play those mind games with yourself.
I've had that kind of experience where I saw a guy where I saw a guy looking
through his rifle looking at me perfectly at what we call a six o'clock sight
picture and he's going to squeeze and you spot yourself going down.
Good leadership dispels all those kinds of mind games.
Yeah,
questioned.
There are all these images of American soldiers walking around smoking pot beads
around their neck singing rock songs.
Clearly the morale of the American troops broke down Hackworth.
The morale of the American army disintegrated the longer the war went on.
We went there with a professional army that was well led by very fine combat
leaders,
most of whom were World War II or Korea experienced.
I'm talking about senior NCO was and officers.
They had a lot of battle experience that were high quality people and they were
badly used from the beginning.
They were traded out,
so we lost the noncommissioned officer corps almost straight away within the
first 18 months of the war.
After that,
there was no unit cohesion.
Every 365 days you had a new unit.
You had no institutional memory.
I know this might seem obvious,
but you got to keep people together.
When you get a good team,
you got to keep them together.
You've got to keep them working together.
Hmm,
no one remembered what happened last month and they kept repeating the same
mistakes again and again and again.
The Americans were in Vietnam for eight years and there were no leaders at the
top willing to raise hell and demand that the training be hard and demand the
standards Behi no one wanted to shake things up in a very,
very unpopular war.
Now,
the finest thing you can do for any young soldier is be mean as hell with him
and whack him in the head when he doesn't do something correctly.
Make certain that he knows his job and knows how to do it right because if he
does it right,
he'll do it right on the battlefield.
But the whole training and leading leadership system,
we're asking how can we resolve this disintegrating morale problem?
We can resolve it by getting them are and are delivering cold beer and coke and
ice cream at night and hot food.
This is what the generals mentality was.
Instead of kicking them in the ass and making them do things right,
screw on their steel pot,
carry their weapon and clean up their ammo.
Get rid of their love beads and not smoke dope.
When I took over my battalion of Delta,
it was grass all over the place.
Before I'd go out with my battalion,
I'd shake everybody down.
I boot people in the butt who even smoked cigarettes because you could smell
tobacco a mile away.
You could see the light from a cigarette a couple of miles away.
In my unit.
You didn't smoke anything and you certainly didn't smoke grass.
It was just a question of discipline.
If you had good leadership and provide a disciplined,
designed not to harass,
but to keep people alive,
the soldiers would react.
So critical distinction.
They're not talking about discipline,
just just designed to harass people and do things for no good reason,
but discipline that's actually there to keep people alive.
Okay?
Continuing.
If they didn't have that,
they would react the other way.
What we saw between 1965 in 1973 when the last two s forces went out was a total
disintegration.
It was an organization that didn't have proper boundaries and didn't have people
insisting on those boundaries.
They were an army of hippies and they didn't have discipline.
Had the war continued for a few more years.
We were seeing at the end by 1973 units refusing to fight.
Well,
we'd have seen a whole army that refuse to fight because it was a most unpopular
war and soldiers were saying,
what am I doing here?
My politicians want me out.
My family wants me out and there's no purpose in being here.
This does not affect my country's security.
All I am is a pawn is stupid war.
They were an army of hippies and didn't have discipline.
Had the war continued for a few more years.
We're seeing at the end,
19 by 1973 units refusing to fight.
Well,
we'd seen in hole we'd see.
We'd have seen a whole army that refuse to fight because it was a most unpopular
war and the soldiers were saying,
what am I doing here?
My politicians want me out,
my family wants me out,
and there's no purpose in me being here.
This does not affect my country security.
All I am is a pawn in a stupid war.
I mean,
okay,
first of all,
obviously we're not talking about every,
every soldier,
every marine,
every service member in Vietnam that was acting that way.
Clearly there was people still doing heroic things and serving to the best of
their ability,
but he's making a broad general statement that if we saw in 1973 some units that
were saying,
hey,
we don't want to fight.
Then if you would have continued down that trajectory eventually been saying,
Hey,
wait a second.
There'd be a lot more to units that would be saying that
next.
How did your soldiers,
particularly your fresh recruits cope with not knowing who the enemy was?
Okay.
Hackworth.
When a soldier would arrive in Vietnam,
badly trained from the USA,
not prepared for the war,
my procedure was that each unit form their own training program at division
level.
The young recruit would go through this training up to two weeks and his
particular in his particular area of operations.
For example,
looking after your feet in the Mekong Delta,
keeping your ammo dry and things of this nature.
After they finish that division level training,
they would come to a unit.
Normally I would talk to my soldiers,
welcomed them to the unit,
assigned them to a rifle company.
My standard operating procedure was to assign a young recruit to an old soldier
in the same foxhole.
That soldier would be his buddy.
A veteran would get a green recruit or fresh meat as they called them and he
would take that new guy and pass his knowledge to him.
Question,
where your soldiers ever reluctant to fight Hackworth?
I had the ability to motivate people even though a guy might be a pacifist in a
few days.
He was hunting for Charlie.
I never had a problem in terms of getting soldiers to fight.
Question,
were you ever frightened?
Can you remember a moment when you were frightened?
Hackworth.
I spent eight years on battlefields as a soldier and I'm sure that there what?
That there aren't very many minutes of those eight years that I wasn't
frightened.
Okay.
It's something that lives in your stomach.
It's just churning all the time.
As the bullets starts snapping in the intensity of combat increases that
churning increases,
but it's always there as long as you're in a dangerous situation.
You've got it and you're carrying it with you.
On your back
question,
did your soldiers have any compunction about shooting civilians on the chance
that they were Viet Cong Hackworth?
I think the average American soldier perceived the enemy as,
but for the grace of God there go I,
and they were reluctant to shoot somebody unless they knew they were the enemy.
Okay.
But if the guy we're coming at him at night,
if the guy we're walking in an area he shouldn't be in and had a weapons or
something like that,
the way I trained my soldiers was to react to automatically.
Okay.
Don't get the thinking process going.
When you see a right cross come at,
you block it with your left hand and go with a right hook.
I never had problems with soldiers being reluctant to fight.
Of course this is,
this is different then you know the SLA Marshall Report of people not wanting to
fight and it's also,
you know,
I'd be,
I say this and sometimes people freak out about it when I say don't think right.
It's I'm thinking,
Hey,
your alarm clock goes off in the morning.
Don't think you just get up and you do what you're supposed to do.
Oh you,
you're,
you're supposed to work out.
Don't think about it.
Just go do it.
And that's what he's saying for a more important situation.
Oh,
there's an enemy threat.
Don't think about it.
Do what you're supposed to do.
Yeah.
Would it surprise you to know that the chief concierge at the Continental Hotel
Saigon's top hotel was in fact working for the Vietcong Hackworth?
It wouldn't surprise me.
At Tet of [inaudible] 68 the secretary of the,
to the commanding general of the US forces in Vietnam,
General Westmoreland was found holding an AK 47 with the whole Vietnamese
apparatus.
I never once trusted a Vietnamese.
I never trusted a Vietnamese general.
I never allowed a Vietnamese inside my camp,
my Firebase.
If I were going to meet a Vietnamese colonel,
I would meet him outside my Firebase because I didn't trust him.
I assumed everybody was Vietcong.
Question.
And these are the people you were meant to be fighting for Hackworth.
That's right.
And that was my attitude.
The soldiers from the ninth division hated the South Vietnamese soldiers more
than they did the Viet Cong.
So what he's saying right there is,
I'm going to read that again.
My soldiers from the ninth division hated the South Vietnamese soldiers more
than they did the Vietcong.
That's horrible situation.
They saw them coming and going out.
They saw them going out on operations and not beating the enemy,
but avoiding the enemy.
They called it search and avoid where it was supposed to be.
Search and destroy.
My battalion could go all the way through the same area and come back bloodied
and battered.
That really got to my guys.
I was walking the perimeter one night.
I used the British system of Stan too in the evening where everybody was at
their post with a weapon ready to go.
Just as the sun was going down.
One of my snipers said,
sir,
how's the body count today?
And I said,
not so good.
We only had eight or nine for the day for the battalion.
And he said,
well,
I'll get you two more before I could stop him.
He took out a sniper rifle.
I looked down at the end of the weapon to see you where it was pointed and it
was pointed at two South Vietnamese soldiers guarding a bridge.
About 40 meters from my perimeter.
I knocked the weapon up before he had a chance to scream,
squeeze off around.
This was the attitude of a lot of soldiers.
They didn't like the South Vietnamese because they didn't pull their weight.
Question,
why did massacres occur in Vietnam?
Hackworth?
Well,
the big massacre was me lie Lieutenant William Calley and Captain Medina where
the principal characters involved in that act.
Why did they have that occur?
It occurred a number of reasons.
The soldiers were frustrated.
They were mainly frustrated because of mines and booby traps and because they
could never find the enemy,
they were just tripping through minefields and seeing their mates blown away,
never grabbing hold of the enemy and getting into a real fight.
Okay.
Then there's a lot of people in a village and then in Saturday takes over and
they just start blowing human beings away.
It's also about bad leadership.
Okay.
Lieutenant Calley had gone through officer candidate school.
He'd gone through three separate courses,
was found wanting in leadership and two of them had had been recycled instead of
being booted out.
Yeah.
The military was into a numbers game and didn't want to have hot,
have a tri high attrition rate for their officers.
They kept recycling someone until they graduated.
Okay.
So here's a guy who never should have been trusted more than an army.
Pfc Ends up a lieutenant.
Okay.
He's with a platoon of soldiers who are extremely frustrated because of mines
and booby traps and he doesn't have the leadership ability to control them to
say stop that fire.
Yeah.
I think massacres occur when you don't have strong leadership,
when you don't have soldiers who are extremely well trained and well disciplined
and well controlled by their leaders.
That's what happened.
Okay.
All those components fell apart
and I think the book that we covered on the meal,
I'm masker actually gave even better details to me.
Obviously it gave better details cause it's a full book,
but I really was,
one of the key things I remember is I remember how the intelligence escalated.
It escalated and I'll tell you something else he saying that,
okay.
You know
that lieutenant Calley couldn't stop them.
Lieutenant Calley led that masker.
He led the masker.
It wasn't him saying,
Oh,
I can't get control of the guys know.
He was actually doing the massacre and they were fine.
They were actually following him.
And that wraps up that,
that wraps up the interview.
It's kind of an abrupt ending.
I don't know why it's so abrupt.
I looked around to see if there was anything that was missing,
but that's,
that's how the,
that's how the interview ends.
But I wanted to go to it from there.
I want to just grab a couple sections out of the Vietnam Primer.
Again,
this is the book that that Hackworth wrote with Sla Marshall when they got back
for when it got back from this tour of Vietnam a few months long and they went
and talk,
debriefed all kinds of people.
And again,
there's all kinds of tactical level lessons in here.
I mean like real tactical doubling security,
contending with the jungle security on the trail,
the company and movement,
field intelligence.
I mean there's the defensive perimeter.
It's just various,
there is also a very short book.
It's not even a hundred pages long.
Um,
and like I said,
if you want to get this,
if you're in military,
you might be able to use this.
If you're leading up,
if you're a platoon leader,
you probably get some decent lessons learned out of this,
but this isn't one of those books that translates directly to business because
it's actually not,
it's not about leadership.
It's about the tactics of
an infantry platoon of infantry company.
So,
but that being said,
of course there are some,
there are some lessons and what's interesting to me as also as I found these
leadership lessons,
they're not just leadership lessons beyond being leadership lessons.
There's a lot of lessons here for
you as a person for me as a person,
and you start taking the leadership lessons from Vietnam primer and applying
them to yourself.
I think you could see a lot of crossover
starting from a leadership perspective though.
Here we go.
Vietnam primer
back to the book are mistakes in Vietnam are neither new nor startling.
They are not something we can blame on the mysteries of warfare.
They are the same problems that had been haunting small unit commanders since
before Gideon.
In peace or war.
These errors spell the difference between professionalism and mediocrity.
Many young leaders and chanted by the Hollywood image of war approach combat
with the good guy versus the bad guy attitude,
but there is no similarity between what John Wayne gets away with on the screen
and the hot hard facts of a firefight.
A small unit leader in combat cannot afford to have a film heroes,
devil may care attitude toward training,
discipline and basic soldiering in the recipe for battle.
Victory.
Well led and disciplined soldiers are the main ingredient soldiers who have been
conditioned through training to react by habit.
When constructed,
when confronted with the searing realities of engagement,
the habits learned in training,
good or bad are the same habits that move the soldier in combat.
A leader then must ensure that each of his soldiers as well trained and has
developed good habits,
habits,
so deeply ingrained through correct teaching and intensive practice that even
under the pressure of fear and sudden danger,
each soldier automatically will do the right thing.
Check
continuing.
There is no magic formula or sweat lists solution by which one can achieve this
goal.
There's no,
there's no hack.
Leaders may approach training for combat only with intense accepting as gospel
the timeless truth that better trained men live longer on the battlefield.
No military unit is ever completely trained.
There will always be a weak area that requires additional time and effort.
The wise commander uses all available time to train his unit.
He never says good enough
leaders must accept the old but absolute maximum.
The more sweat on the training field,
the less blood on the battlefield.
Combat is too serious of business to permit.
Easy excuse of even one mistake.
Never quit checking,
check everything all the time.
Weapons for cleanliness aid,
men for supplies,
centuries for alertness and the camp for field sin sanitation.
Another weakness among junior leaders is the inaccurate report of the estimate
of the situation.
Estimates are many times either so greatly exaggerated or so watered down that
they are not meaningful to the next higher commander who must make critical
decisions as to troop employment,
an allocation of combat power.
The confusion and noise of the battlefield are two reasons why faulty estimates
are made over emotionalism and the sense of the drama are others.
These factors coupled with the judgment of an impulsive commander who feels that
he must say something on the radio,
even if it is wrong,
are the crux of the problem.
Commanders must report the facts as they see them on the battlefield.
If they don't know the situation,
they must just say that.
Yeah,
and again,
those are just a couple little lessons learned out of Vietnam primer and
you know,
I think one of the things,
like I said,
there's a lot of things that you can take from what Hackworth talks about and we
talks about leadership
and you can actually apply it to yourself.
You can apply it to your personal life.
And some of the things that he just said,
thinking about some of these are mistakes are nothing new or startling.
[inaudible]
think about that.
Most of the time.
Most of the time,
think about this.
Most of the time when you make a mistake,
it's something that you already knew.
You actually know you're making the mistake when you're making it.
Hmm.
Here's another thing he says,
errors.
Spell the difference between professionalism,
a mediocrity.
It's the little things.
It's the little mistakes that you make.
Next thing he thinks says disciplined soldiers are the main ingredient in
victory.
Well,
guess what?
The main ingredient in victory in your life is discipline.
Yeah.
All Day.
He says there's no magic formula or sweat lists solution by which one can
achieve their goals.
I think he just said,
there is no,
there is no shortcut.
There is no hack.
There's no sweat list solution.
You,
you're gonna have to work.
Then he says this,
no military unit is ever completely trained.
Guess what?
Neither are you.
Neither am I.
There is always weakness to work on.
Always a lot of them.
Hmm.
He says this in Vietnam,
primer combat is two series of business to permit.
Easy excuse of even one mistake.
Now think about this.
Okay.
Comments two series of business.
Why is that?
It's because you can die,
but guess what?
We're all going to die.
So why would we,
why would we allow ourselves to make easy,
easy excuses?
Why would you allow that calm?
That's life and death,
so his life,
so you shouldn't allow yourself these easy excuses.
And then the last section
that he dead,
he talks about that I read,
it can absolutely be applied.
It can absolutely,
absolutely be applied.
He says another weakness,
common among junior leaders is the inaccurate reporting of the estimate of the
situation.
They are either so exaggerated or wolf so watered down that they are not
meaningful.
Now again,
if you apply this to yourself,
what you realize
is that you got these junior leaders that they're lying to the chain of command.
I mean they're,
they're exaggerating or they're watering things down,
but they're basically lying to their chain of command.
And how does that translate to us?
We lie to ourselves.
Mm.
That's how it translate to us.
We lie to ourselves.
We don't tell ourselves the way things really are.
And when we do that,
then we can't fix our problems.
If we can't fix our problems,
we're not going to improve.
So we have to be truthful to ourselves.
I have to be truthful to myself.
You have to be truthful to yourself.
You have to stop rationalizing,
stop making excuses.
Stop telling yourself little water down of where you're really at.
Tell yourself the truth
so that you can get where you want to go.
You can be who you want to beat.
You could be,
oh,
you should be
who'd you should be.
When you do what you know you should do.
When you pay attention to the little things,
when you implement discipline,
true and unflinching and on mitigated discipline in your life.
When you stop,
when you stop trying to find a sweat list solution,
when you look for weaknesses to work on,
when you allow no easy excuses and all that starts,
when you stop lying to yourself,
can you stop lying to yourself?
That's when you can become who you know you should be.
When you tell yourself the truth about where you are,
so you can make sure you are in the right place.
And if you're not in the right place,
that you can get yourself on the path to get there.
The path of discipline,
the path of hard work and the path of
truth.
And I think
that's all I've got for tonight.
So
Echo Charles,
speaking of the path,
the path,
the path of truth,
we're open to any suggestions you may or may not have on how we can get on that
path and then go ahead and stay on that path.
Stay on the path.
Yeah.
I feel like
more and more of us are on the path.
That's what I feel like you don't at the roll call,
roll call roll call that we just got done,
which was an event.
If you don't know for military first responders,
law enforcement,
paramedics,
firefighters,
there was a lot of people there that are straight up on the path readout
legitimately on the path.
Yup.
Yeah.
And it's one of those deals where,
you know how,
like when you hear a certain story and then you know,
uh,
about someone and you're like,
oh,
like,
Dang,
that's impressive.
And then you hear it again and again and again,
and then you're like,
okay,
you know,
I'm kind of used to it.
I don't feel like I've gotten used to this at all because everyone's story's
kind of different,
you know?
So it kind of exposes this element of like re like just immense individuality of
a person,
you know?
So it's,
it's Kinda like,
um,
I dunno.
It's like,
I don't know,
maybe like your kid's birthday or something that happens over and over again,
but never gets old,
you know,
kind of that kind of situation.
Um,
there was a guy,
he was like,
and he just told me this while we were listening to you guys do Jujitsu and you
just right in the middle of it,
just kind of in my ear kind.
He's like,
dude,
I lost 70 pounds just because I'm on the path.
Geez,
guys were just guys and girls,
females,
boys and girls.
Men and women were walking up to me and like,
show me pictures.
Yeah.
Hey,
this is what I looked like 13 months ago.
Yeah.
I've lost 38 pounds or whatever.
Awesome.
I got promoted.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's awesome.
So yes,
you are correct.
There's a lot of people on the path.
Kids,
everything.
Kids ever.
Oh yeah.
People.
I made little videos for kids.
I was looking at videos,
kids,
kids doing pull ups,
kids doing Jujitsu,
little warrior kids straight up on the path,
knowing the,
knowing the Gettysburg address.
Hey,
look at this kid.
Look at my son.
He knows the Gettysburg address.
He's six.
Look at my daughter.
That's six pull ups right there.
Yep.
You know how many she could do last year?
Zero.
You see what I'm saying?
Yes sir.
Do you think it's going to get crowded on the bat?
No.
It'll get wider.
Maybe the path gets wider.
It gets wise.
Everyone's kind of on their own path,
but there's just a unified,
yeah.
Oh,
there's,
there's common ground on the path.
On a fundamental level,
actually there's,
there's immense commonality down there,
but the path is big enough to maintain the not going to get,
there's not gonna be a traffic jam on the path.
Nope.
And in fact,
it's the opposite.
It's the opposite.
The more people have a path,
the faster it goes.
More momentum.
Yeah.
Shoot.
So weird how you can take leadership principles and apply them to yourself.
Yeah.
So it's almost like a lie to yourself.
Think about that.
Because you think about the little lies you tell yourself.
Oh yeah,
they utilize.
So long time ago,
my mom was like overweight.
I didn't know.
I mean,
I guess I knew that,
I don't know when you're a little kid,
you don't know.
And My,
and then so she got on the path back in the day and,
and she lost a bunch of weight and my dad said,
hey,
you know what?
I'm going to get your mom for her birthday.
I was like,
what?
He's like a mirror,
a full size mirror because she lost a bunch of ways.
You're very good,
you know,
whatever now.
And I was like,
cool.
You know,
that's something,
I don't stuff,
whatever furniture was a furniture,
good,
good job,
dad,
whatever,
you know,
kind of.
And then like I kind of thought about it and I'm thinking about it more now.
It's like,
man,
you know what that,
you know what that says that says that like,
you know,
she was like overweight and she was from my dad to know that,
and to take action.
Like that means that he knew that she was in a way,
in one way or another,
avoiding the mirror.
And I would say yes,
straight up avoiding it,
but she just didn't want to see herself in the mirror mean you said same thing I
said,
I guess
I said a little bit of different way,
but she didn't want to see yourself in the mirror.
Right?
Like if you have a,
and you kind of think about it,
sure you have a mirror in the bathroom and it's sort of it,
but like,
I don't know where,
where else do we have mirrors,
right?
Like I dunno in the bedroom or something.
You don't want girls get ready.
I don't know.
I'm comparing it to my current situation.
I have no idea of the mirror in the bathroom medicine cabinet.
That's it.
Yeah.
I guess I guess my,
you know what,
you're right,
because both my daughters,
my older daughters had mirrors in their room like yeah,
all love.
So they can get ready,
right?
Or they get the outfit,
I dunno.
Mirror,
but for a girl,
I don't know.
Again,
I'm just totally like thinking of my situation.
So,
and yeah,
so like kind of thinking back,
I'm like,
Dang,
we only had the mirror in the bathroom anyway.
So for that to be the case for a mirror to be a good gift where your dad's going
to tell you like,
hey,
how's this as a gift?
It kind of indicates that you don't like cool.
It's like,
oh yeah.
So anyway,
the point is like,
yeah,
we do kind of like to ourselves even if we don't think we're necessarily lying
herself.
She didn't want to admit certain things.
See a mission,
mission lying by omission.
Like I'm not even going to look at myself and therefore I don't full address.
Yeah.
Their and not even a problem,
spending more of my life or whatever.
It's like,
yeah.
It's like lied by omission.
Like if you don't do Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Like No.
If you don't do Jujitsu all one day,
if you don't do Jujitsu one day,
let's say there's,
let's say there's an a month,
there's four days that you didn't do Jujitsu,
three of those could have been legitimate days where you legitimately,
for whatever reason,
couldn't do to one of those days might've been predicated on a lie that you told
yourself.
Right?
Yeah.
I just don't have time today.
When what you really did was you extended some work,
an extra cause that's a,
there's a weird time.
There's a word time thing that happens with Jujitsu.
Like,
Hey,
class starts at star class starts at four 30 or class starts at four like,
I'm going to roll at five 30 the guys are everyone's training at six right?
Hey,
we're doing no get six.
Well if I get caught up in something mysteriously and all of a sudden it's six
Oh four at my house.
Uh,
you know what,
I won't even get there until six 20 or six 15 by the time I get changed,
you know the guys will probably be done.
You just told yourself a bunch of lies.
Well there I would say because there is no,
that's not nothing.
The this at my house gets called the Jujitsu window.
Oh okay.
Cause there is no gym.
The Leica then I should have said this then the light came earlier.
The light came on,
which was like I should really get this done right now.
Yeah,
no you could get that done when you get home later.
But you just,
you just extended that window cause you wanted to shut that you did to wind on
yourself.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That's what happens.
And that window is like that's a weird psychological area to be in.
Cause it's cocaine.
I call it at home,
I call it the Jujitsu window.
That's why it's kind of like,
what am I looking for?
Will be like,
Hey,
can you,
can you just go later?
I was like,
no,
you can't.
There's a,
and it's super,
super narrow.
Just like I said when it's six Oh four and you're supposed to be there at six is
that,
cause here's the factors one,
everyone will be either finishing up or late in the rounds,
you'll get one roll.
So kind of the later you show up,
the less training you're going to get,
less training you get the less worth it it is to get dressed and get all your
stuff together and go.
I'm not saying it's going to be not worth it.
Yeah.
But it becomes less and less worth it.
Right.
So there's that.
And then there's like the social things like,
Oh,
you're the guy that shows up on the last round where everyone's tired.
What are you doing dude?
You know,
there's kind of like a stigma with that.
When somebody says that to me,
I'm like,
I live.
I just got done working.
I came here as quickly as I could and I'll tell you what,
I'll do 35 burpees right now.
You bed,
we can train you.
Yeah.
And that's of course that's not cause because that's not always the case.
I mean with you,
I can't even really ever actually done that before.
And just your answer there kind of indicated like that's never happened to you.
Has it like kind of thing.
There's,
there's one big,
Eric can be like,
oh you're showing up.
I'm like Bro,
he always has any,
any also did like one round.
Go on to here.
Come on,
you don't care.
Another thing I'll say is if he's done anything else that day,
he'll tell you about it.
Like,
Hey,
I went and ran stairs this morning.
I'm like that's cool.
I squatted did sprints,
went surfing and now I'm here to train what
yet.
But nonetheless,
did you use the window?
It's real.
You know,
cause you'll,
you'll let me just miss the opportunity.
I don't mean this in a hostile way.
How come?
Sometimes when the Jujitsu class starts,
let's say it,
let's say we're going to train at had 11 how come?
Sometimes you show up at like 1148
but it seems like your window is way just off alignment.
I don't know.
Let's call it a Sunday,
right?
We all know what time we start training.
Right.
And then sometimes you come rolling in.
I mean,
you weren't talking about you.
You're like,
Hey,
well,
you know,
you're 15 minutes late,
these guys can be done.
I'm,
I'm an hour and a half rounds and you're rolling in like bowing up to me.
Well,
I'm going to bullet regardless.
Then of course I'm not going to be saying,
hey,
you know,
you're showing up late and I'm kinda tired.
No,
I'm going to say,
okay,
well you showing up.
We'll do what we gotta do you know what it is?
Okay.
Because I have no idea.
I have no idea how someone could be knowing that all of his training partners
that want to train with him are there at 10 o'clock or at 11 o'clock and that
individual decides,
Hey,
I'll just show up at 1148 and call it good.
This is what happened on Sunday.
The normal routine has always been,
I come at noon for Greg trains.
No g train.
Okay,
okay.
And anytime you for two,
three,
four years,
you've shown up at that time.
See me in a ball of sweat.
Yeah.
rounds deep.
No,
if you,
if you remember correctly there,
there are times that I'll come,
it'll be me,
you and Andy just going round Robin.
There will be those times but and you're looking at the amount of times that
Andy and I have done that.
It's a very large number.
I know.
But here,
this is why though.
So it has to do with like my whole over a life scheduling.
See what I'm saying?
So noon is the best time and I get to crate trained with Greg and you know,
all this stuff and then you'll text me like the day before or seen her going to
freaking tent.
Oh.
And I'm like
hardcore,
crazy schedule.
I need to call your assistant to get to put in your calendar
the day before.
Anyway,
I'll text Andy and like,
I'd be like,
Hey,
I'm heading to the gym in 15 minutes.
He's like,
I'm on my way Thursday night,
Thursday,
Sunday morning,
whatever.
Bro.
What if,
okay.
What if you and Andy had Trump plans to train at 10 and I text you,
hey,
let's train at one 30 I'd say no,
be here at 10 30 cause because we're not training then we're training at at 10 I
still don't understand why one 30 hey,
you can train cause that's what time we trained.
Well,
what about one three?
What's the difference?
We've got other things to do.
There you go.
We have other things to do.
So I had like obligations as far as scheduling goes normal.
This is not like a random thing that happens.
This is the steady state for years.
Yeah.
they're probably counting yourself.
Let's be too early for that.
I do,
I do.
1148 is when you come in,
we'd come in and you see sweat.
Yeah.
Are you a little bit bummed out?
Yes.
Not Adjust your schedule.
Why wouldn't you calendar yourself?
Well,
because it's weird.
It's like I'm on this,
it's on,
I'm on this like psychological pat.
Like lying to yourself.
No,
no,
no.
I'm still,
I'm not lying to yourself.
Hackworth says no,
I'm going to lie.
I'm going to go ahead and assume that I am lying to myself until,
so I'm going to find it and admit it to myself.
But this is what it feels.
Lighter comes the light here because
it could be like,
this could be fun,
like all week I do whatever,
whatever,
whatever.
Right?
And I trained at a certain time on Sunday.
My normal like habitual kind of routine on Sunday is a noon training.
So everything before noon that I do and have to do or whatever,
that's just sort of in place.
It doesn't take much mental work.
But then if you're like texted me the night before saying,
Hey Tan,
I'm like,
oh man.
Kinda in my mind I'm already kind of committed to the noon to myself though,
truly seems say,
Oh,
this isn't just a lie.
Then he was like a whole conspiracy.
Run against yourself.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
It's not ridiculous because I do have other things to do with Eddie Bravo
or consider this like,
okay,
so let's say I have x,
Y,Z ,
one,
two,
three,
four things I got to do before noon.
And then when I get back,
I dunno,
that's the thing.
But they log their time.
They are time sensitive in the sense that I do have to do them.
So if I plan to do them before training,
now I've got to shift all that other stuff.
We're like,
you know,
and there's other people involved,
all this stuff anyway,
so it's usually the case,
but looking for,
no one's going to follow you down the path.
You're right.
That's the thing.
And now that I don't know what's real funny,
and you know,
this is the truth.
This is,
this is,
this is good actually at the end of the day.
Good.
So all have a lot of see this situation that I'm telling you and you're like
laughing at me and telling me how I'm lying to myself that this situation goes
on in a lot of ways with me.
But yeah,
but you're going to confess,
I'm confessing this.
So when I tell you like out loud stuff and some of the stuff is like I just
start telling you and just the look on your face.
I'm like probably know the answer rating.
I know already.
And this is one of those things where before I got into it,
I was like for real committed to it.
Like this is like true.
That's how it is and this is the reason.
And sometimes they'll come train with you guys,
you know,
when I do all this work to shift it around.
But if I were to just shift it around and be like,
that's the new schedule,
like I could do it.
It's a miracle.
All right bro.
You know what,
I just,
I just realized it's very good.
Uh,
uh,
very uh,
very solid quality.
I'd have talked about,
I always talk about people like everyone's allergic to criticism.
Like everyone hates getting criticized,
like you told me to do something different than what the 40 talking about.
Yeah.
You're actually very open to criticism and I think part of it is because,
well,
maybe it's because when I criticize you,
I'm not telling you like,
Hey,
do what I do.
I'm just saying like,
Hey,
you tell me what your reason is and we'll figure it out.
If you're like,
I realize you yourself are not over on my side of the table over here.
We think we suspect were suspect of the,
of the statement.
Very suspect.
So there it is.
Anyways,
what the,
the thing is maybe we can adjust that.
Maybe we can,
we can snuff out that lie.
We can find out what the truth isn't.
The truth is you should be training with your training,
your normal training partners.
Yeah.
On the Sunday whenever that,
whenever that that that agreed upon time is out there.
Ted Cox,
Nice.
11 o'clock at night,
10 o'clock at night.
You know it's nice to get hold gym.
You mean the whole gym?
I just empty.
Oh yeah.
You just curate,
ain't just gifts getting after it.
Yeah.
That is.
Remember,
remember when we first opened this gym and you were like,
hey,
we got new before the mats were all even in and you were like this new mats
downstairs.
Remember that?
And then there was still,
I wanted to test them out with the new maps.
Yeah and we're rolling.
We're rolling Abbott like
pretty long as far as two guys rolling now.
And then you were like,
isn't it just so awesome when you have your own gym?
But it's true.
I was like Dang man.
Must Be.
Cause it's like you just had the whole bill,
you know it is very nice.
Just Sir that as a nice thing to have.
Speaking of the Jujitsu,
okay,
look everyone we're going to do too.
That's what we're doing.
If you're on the path that we're looking or interested,
if the path is right for you kind of situation.
If someone's Geek curious and it is,
yeah,
yes.
And you're doing you just so you're going to need a g because he can't just,
just do know Geek.
As tempting as that might be good.
It is tempting.
Do some Geek.
It's tempting until you say,
well,
do you want to be so good in one thing and this be lost with something that's so
close and they both compliment each other.
Yes.
They really do.
Yeah.
I did a bunch of rounds of Geeky in at peak PMMA.
Yeah,
it was good.
Good.
Some good rounds.
Did you do two players out there?
That's some good times,
but it was Augie as Augie.
I was like,
I told JP,
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm not bringing a gay.
And he's like,
hey,
just bring your belt and I'll get you give you need it just for the class then
you can roll Geena.
No,
he afterwards.
So I'm like,
okay,
cool.
And then I put the key on how to Geek is one of his geese pants were too tight.
I couldn't move my legs was,
it's super ugly.
No,
it was uh,
it was an origin key cause one of the warrior ds,
the lightweight ones.
Anyways,
long story short,
got a bunch of good Ramsen Nikki.
So yeah,
you're going to need to get,
if you're on the path and you started Jujitsu or you've already started,
you just so you're going to need a gate,
what can you do?
You need,
that's the question.
That's always a question.
You get an origin Giesen lot of question.
Not Anymore.
No.
There it is.
Boom.
Question answered.
Origin Geek,
go to origin main.com.
That's where you get your geek on made in America.
All made in America from beginning to end.
There's some rash guards do for Nogi,
so boom.
Get them both and get your Jujitsu established.
Did you say rash guards?
Yes.
Okay.
You got rash guards and other,
what do you call this?
Normal clothes.
That's what I say.
Apparel one day you like.
That's,
that's,
that's not,
not,
not the thing to say.
No,
no,
no.
I said I,
I said apparel to clear it with you.
You said cool.
No fashion though.
Yeah.
Even though he,
he's,
he has one pinky in the fashion
and he's got more than a pig.
He's got a whole art thing going on.
Respect and law.
Joe,
what were you doing?
Oh yeah,
we're taking the picture at the immersion camp.
Yeah.
And he started like Pete started getting all,
hey you come over here a little bit.
Hey we need to,
and was really taken some artistic control.
The situation I said to Joe,
I said here comes the big artists Guy Comin out
laughing everyone.
Yeah.
So he's got more than just a pinky in there.
Both pinkies at a minimum.
Well good cause not everybody is like you and some people they liked that
fashion element to what they were.
I was going to talk to Pete about this.
So Pete and he's listening right now.
Sure.
I was actually a very accurate statement when I said when we had this
conversation before.
My ultimate goal of fashion is to make no impression.
Yeah.
And I guess that's completely the wrong thing to do.
Yes sir.
It is.
But that's my thing.
If you,
I want my clothing to look in such a way that when you look at me,
you just see,
you know,
what you see what normal.
Okay.
This still feel normal.
Like just normal clothes.
Like you wouldn't be able to say,
I bet that guy now the exception that I have to as I got the victory MMA tee
shirt.
That's your thing.
Yeah.
And the reason I have that is because I have a bunch of them and I just wear the
same thing every day.
So I have that little thing.
But if you see me traveling where I'm not wearing tee shirt,
I'm going to,
we were on something or you,
you just think,
oh this is just a normal person or not.
This person has no nothing.
Right,
right.
Oh thing.
Yeah.
Well,
so if you,
I don't want to call this a mistake,
but here's the thing that makes it almost like an antiquated kind of scenario.
Okay.
Cause you're like I'm,
my goal is you said my goal is to be normal,
whatever.
If that's your goal is not to make a statement.
Right.
You know,
your,
that's your fashion.
They're fats,
your statement.
So by just by way of your whole discourse,
you're doing what you're trying not to do.
It's kind of like,
um,
well I guess I,
I guess what,
I guess I should have phrased it differently.
What I normally would wear is just stuff that looks normal and leaves,
although I guess,
yeah,
no,
I guess there is,
I guess in this day and age you have to make some kind of an effort.
So I guess in a horrible way I'm making some kind of a fashion effort.
Yeah.
No,
you don't what you need or who you are though.
This is what it feels like.
Anyway.
I did it however you want to explain this.
What if you'll remember Bruce Lee when he was like on the boat,
he was going to know which one it was and another dragon.
I don't know.
He's on the boat.
Right?
Going over to,
and the guy's like,
what's your style?
And he's like,
my style,
he's fighting without fighting.
That's your style right there.
It's fashion without fashion.
Browse looking at old pictures of us.
Yeah,
like all like I dunno,
like Oh nine 10 dang,
that's almost 10 years ago.
And work is like me aid.
I think ti was there and then you know,
it's like whatever you being you same you by the way,
same exactly.
Drug called normal faith and guess what you're wearing victory tee shirt.
That's your whole uniform or got a lot of them and it's,
you know,
very straight forward I it anyways.
Fashion without fashion and that's the joc and luckily Pete's got your back and
you know it's cool.
This is cool because Pete also has a sense of that.
Who else is making a black on black sweatshirt,
right?
There's no,
you can't see the origin of you can see it but you got to,
you know you're not,
you're not drawing attention to yourself.
Yeah,
I guess that's the thing,
right?
I'm trying not to draw attention to yourself.
Just be a little bit more laid back with that stuff.
Yeah,
because you guys used to make fun of me at seal team two cause I,
I had,
that was when I was competing all the time.
Did you?
Jitsu tournaments.
So I had like,
they used to just like the main thing you'd get from a juicy German,
a little cheesy metal and a tee shirt,
tee shirt.
So I had all these Jews.
Every,
I had a different t shirt.
I had a different you did through t shirt.
So there guess what I was doing was just wearing what I was given.
But that's what it kind of stood out.
Yes.
Even though these are all just free tee shirts.
Well,
although I paid for the Higgs and Gracie one,
I had to take some Gracie teacher.
I've paid some money for that one.
That's cool.
$12.
The old Pecos Street Academy,
some old school people remember that right now we're best in the west.
Best of the West.
It was the [inaudible] attorney.
Yeah,
I remember that.
But that was little later.
I'm talking old school grappling games.
I'm talking Joe Merera in school.
The Gracie,
what was that?
Gracie invitational.
Greasy nationals.
Gracie,
I think it says canal.
It's called the grace net.
Neutral grounds is going old school.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Sorry.
I could go down memory lane with you.
Um,
you know,
it's not do it,
but anyway,
yeah.
[inaudible] get,
get ordered and get all origin stuff for Jujitsu.
That's the,
that's the spot to go.
Even like the joggers and the sweats,
sweat stuff.
Most comfortable in the world.
Boom.
Also supplement.
You can get some supplements,
joint warfare,
getting some Rave Leif Babin he said he went off joint warfare,
I think you said four or five days.
Whatever's on the trip.
And she said his knee started hurting again.
Came back and went back on the joint warfare.
Guess what?
Knee healed up.
He,
I mean he,
I dunno.
Healed but it's no longer sore.
Yeah,
yeah man.
That's all.
You know what's,
you know what's so funny?
It's like me,
I'm all like surprised when it was my experience.
Just like,
you know,
obviously late surprises me enough to tell you about it,
and just like me where it's like,
Dang Bro.
I told them,
I told them we put illegal stuff in joint warfare.
Like I told him,
I was like,
hey man,
don't tell anyone,
but we put some little,
we put some little,
a steroidal and,
and he was all looking at me.
He didn't,
he probably me for 0.3 seconds because he didn't really believe me that much.
But then I was like,
no,
I'm just kidding man.
But
anyway,
a sketch.
But nonetheless,
isn't that supposed?
Isn't that odd though?
That we're all surprised.
Surprise breads?
It's supposed to do that,
you know,
like it's supposed to do these things.
Yeah.
But I think at the level that it does,
it too is a little more the what people expect.
There you go.
Get on the Krill oil too.
Yup.
Now discipline.
Um,
we've got some debates going on on whether Dave,
no,
Dave Burke,
good.
Guilty.
Whether he should be the actual representative.
Clearly he's the representative discipline.
Yes.
But for milk and the full mock train,
he's looking a little lean.
Yeah.
He's lean.
So he is the lien representative mark.
He's the before picture.
That's cold blooded.
You know,
maybe if there's people that are like,
wait,
I don't want to get all big.
Hey Dave Burke,
he's on the milk trained fully on the milk train.
Yeah.
And he's not huge.
Well,
well let's break it down.
So to me personally,
I don't think Dave Burke should be the poster child for milk.
Shouldn't be,
wait,
is he treading on your territory?
I didn't know this is a sensitive issue anyway.
I should have,
I should have read it into this more.
Sorry.
But still the idea,
you know,
you're the representative of the mole.
Check could be technically he could be.
So what protein,
rice protein.
Additional protein.
Because look,
you work out,
you lift,
you do,
you know all this extra hard exercise.
Bloom protein is part of their recovery process.
A big part of the recovery of call them building blocks for lack of a better
term,
whatever.
And boom,
the malt comes in.
Boom.
Right?
But the malt tastes good.
So here and here's this side.
No,
this is why it's important for it to taste good.
This may or may not go against your whole,
actually it will.
No,
I won't.
It seems like what?
But it tastes good.
So let's say I'm like,
I'm on the fence about working out.
I know you can't relate to that part,
but let's say you are,
then you're like wait,
but when I work out I can take the milk.
So it like fits in,
you know it one,
there's one with the other that's the best known.
Those guys that just thought just the supplements alone would get them Jay.
Exactly right.
And that's part of the point cause you don't exist just so everyone knows you
don't have to work out to have milk.
You can have milk without working,
but it will taste better if you worked out well.
If you take milk or any PR like additional protein for the reason you take
protein,
I'm saying and you don't work out,
there's no reason to take it.
True.
Seem saying like any excess calories and settled for the fact that milk tastes
good.
You could actually just take more because there's no reason to eat ice cream and
chocolate chip ice cream except for it tastes really good.
Yeah.
But that's,
that's a slippery slope though.
That's not the path.
So officially,
by the way,
we established this,
this was,
I think I was talking to the leaf.
The opposite of the path is a slippery slope.
Okay?
You can step off the path for 10 minutes for one day,
for one week.
But keep in mind,
the more you're,
the more time you spend off the path fee you're going to slip.
It's a slippery slope.
So boom,
nonetheless,
if your whole mindset is to drink milk,
just because it tastes good,
no exercise,
no this Bruh you,
you're,
that's the wrong path and you're going in the wrong direction.
We'll speed of foot on the slippery slope at that point.
And you kind of facing the wrong way.
Yeah,
that tastes good.
Boom.
Same reason.
But you're not,
you're saying your pizza,
you're two feet are off.
That's true.
Molson one foot's on the path.
Mulkin working out.
You're on the path.
Kind of like real quick because we're getting crazy here.
Uh,
we got mint chocolate chip,
we've got peanut butter chocolate,
Dave Burks favorite mint chocolate is my favorite.
What's your favorite mint?
Yeah,
but you make some cause you're psycho.
And now new two new flavors are out vanilla gorilla and we got a chocolate,
which is called the darkness.
When I eat vanilla gorilla,
I was like,
Hey,
no,
we need to make it vanilla gorilla.
And then he wrote,
he like paused and we were texting and he's like,
wait,
seriously?
And I was like yes.
Then he made the little crazy looking vanilla grill,
a little white gorilla.
So anyways,
vanilla gorilla is the name and the chocolate of course is called darkness.
And if you don't know there are layers to both those comments.
If you know about the darkness and know that one.
And if you know,
if you know life well then you can figure out the vanilla gorilla.
Yes,
these are all impeccable things can impeccable.
That might not be the correct word,
but they are impeccable things to Stan.
Keep you on the path and indeed 100% indeed.
Also Jack was doors called Jocko store.
This is where you can get shirts and hoodies and hats,
more rash guards,
different feel different,
not physical field but different,
different.
There was Kinda,
this is pretty cool at the roll call when we did Jujitsu,
there was people in the,
I've never done Jujitsu before area.
They had rash guards.
Yeah they had Jocko store rash guards that def core rash cards
and they had origin rash guards.
Yeah.
A lot of stuff.
A lot.
That's a lot of that.
When you just look at that one room,
it was filled with a lot of stuff that's made in America,
which is a big deal.
It was.
And that says a lot for someone who's never done you just to get,
they have the rash guard.
So that's kind of like in a way,
I don't want to say commitment necessarily cause it's a little bit,
I bet you there was people there that said I'm going to try the Jujitsu and I'm
going to continue down the path as people know you got to get on the Jujitsu
path.
Yeah.
That's just part of the deal.
I think I questioned me.
Yeah.
At the roll call after we got done teaching.
He's like,
so his Jujitsu,
the best,
you know,
thing to start with
as opposed to anything.
I was like,
yeah man,
we did you hear everything?
I just said,
come on man.
Yeah,
do it.
Yeah.
I said,
what about,
and he said,
what about like striking though?
And I said,
well,
you know,
start with boxing,
get,
get to Moitai when you get good at boxing,
you can start open it up a little bit.
He's like,
oh,
should I start with that?
And I was like,
no,
cause if I grab you,
that's not gonna work anymore.
And if some bad guy grabs you,
that's not going to work anymore.
So anyways,
and I said,
yeah,
cool.
I always try to put myself in,
in like outside of my own brain,
because you know,
when like if someone asks me detach,
if they're like,
hey,
is you did to the best martial,
I'm like,
not even the other options.
Don't even enter,
you know,
it's just like,
yes,
yes.
Like constant,
yes thing.
But I'm like,
wait,
you know,
let me,
let me consider this.
You know,
um,
like try to let go some of my bias.
Anyway,
Dr Jocko store,
we've got some good stuff on there.
If you want to represent the path,
discipline equals freedom.
Straight up.
Cause it does.
It's the uniform for the path.
It is.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's a good way of putting it.
Oh,
I would say there's a new discipline equals freedom.
Sure.
Yeah.
Is it different?
No.
Said standing out.
These things are all kind of,
you know,
that's just how these,
these aren't fashion items.
Well,
but they do make us,
they do.
There's this dichotomy to everything,
my friend.
Yes sir.
There is.
If you want to represent,
you want to represent it in the wild by there were,
there were guys with the shirt that you design with my head on it,
but I haven't,
I don't think I've ever felt more honored in my life.
That was pretty good.
It was pretty solid.
Multiple people wearing the Dang shirt.
You decide can I designed or I guess you'd called Nag shirt.
Yeah.
Well,
you know now you're going to keep the layers anyway.
If you want to represent Jocko,
store.com also,
if you want to support the message,
the word,
what do you guys call it?
Spreading the word as we're passing the word,
spread the word,
pass the words the word.
Yet you want to pass the word,
subscribe to the podcast on iTunes and stitcher and wherever you live.
I mean it seems obvious,
but if you haven't subscribed,
subscribe and don't about that.
Don't forget about that warrior kid podcast.
Yes,
which
is your,
you're going to learn lessons from it for sure.
Your kids are going to dig it and it's going to get your kids.
Are we going to talk about the pathway?
It's going to get your kids on the path as well,
which is awesome.
I'll Scott though.
They wore your kids soap from Iris Oaks ranch.com that's Aiden.
He's a warrior kid and he's got his own business.
He's making soap and that's awesome.
From goat milk of goats that he raised himself and then he,
he,
the whole process,
he sent me all these pictures of it.
What he actually does.
He's got a manufacturing thing going on in America.
In America.
Yes.
By the way,
goats,
the goats are American goats.
There you go.
Yeah.
And also youtube,
we've got a youtube channel and that is where that is where Ekos legit videos
are.
And he's putting them up on a pretty regular basis and he's got a plan in place
to increase that even more.
Sure.
And as long as that fits his schedule.
And then we got psychological warfare,
that's an album with tracks of me talking and telling you why you should do
something instead of not do something well,
why should not do something instead of do something,
how to stay on the bad reasons.
Slippery slope calls.
There you go.
So get on that.
Yeah,
that's available through all the places you get.
Mp3S.
Yeah.
What about a psychological warfare to,
it's common.
We're working it.
We're working on it.
Yes sir.
Also on it.com/jocko,
by the way,
this is where you can get your other fitness gear.
So remember back in the day we had the uh,
there actually back when,
when you were explaining the essentials of own home gym.
Yes.
Right.
Number one.
So look when you're growing.
Yeah.
Number one is rings,
which I got from on it by the way.
Which Eczema kids enjoy those two.
The other phone for Nice,
nice quality quality.
None the less when you're expanding your home gym in the event of you having a
home gym or even if you don't have a home gym,
this is where you can get the stuff to sort of begin that really good stuff on
there.
A kettle bells is my,
I would say that's my number one number one thing to have.
That would be my recommendation.
You say offerings,
you say rain's do pull ups on kettle bells bro.
Well I know,
well wait,
do you like pull ups?
I like pull up.
Why can't really do them now in your game when you're,
when you're,
when you're 100% yeah,
I mean yes,
but not like you like pull ups.
Like it's,
you know how you have your,
the ones you like.
Like when I started kettlebells,
I really liked him.
I thought was Super Fun because there's a lot.
He had an,
anyway,
they're fine.
I get them from on it and there's a lot of cool other cool stuff on there.
So Yacko on it.com/jocko also Jocko white tea.
You can get the tea bags,
you'd get the can and when you get the tea bags or do you get the can either
one.
It doesn't matter because what you get with that,
you get an 8,000 pound dead lift.
100% guaranteed.
Although I did have one guy complain at roll call.
His dead lifts only 7,400 so probably.
Yeah,
he's probably not.
I told him to get after it harder and then it got some books.
Also the t is available on Amazon and the store and Jocko store and Rocco store.
There you go.
I figure ultimately you we will unify.
Yeah,
well I guess the kind of the goal,
the short term goals kind of make it just available.
Like if you're going to grab the shirt,
rash,
guard,
whatever,
and you're like,
Hey,
let me grab [inaudible].
Good point.
I saw an Amazon store when we were in Dallas or not,
not an Amazon store and Amazon like obvious shipping facility.
This thing was
huge and it was surrounded by trucks that were backed up to it.
You know,
loading docks just,
it was crazy.
It was totally nuts.
And I was like in there somewhere there's something,
there's a little bit of Jocko white tea getting ready to roll out and increase
somebody's dead lift.
I made me happy.
They'll say in there.
They also had books in there.
Yup.
Jocko books.
Yes.
They had way the warrior kid.
You think they had that one nice?
They did.
Yeah,
they absolutely do.
They had the field manual.
So w the way the word kid and Mark's mission,
I signed so many of those books at roll call of the personal messages to the
kids and everything.
The kids are getting on the path.
This is factual.
Awesome.
So get the books for your kids and get them a pull up bar and get them a Jujitsu
class.
Cause that's what they're going to want to do.
And those two things are going to help them through their entire life through
their entire life.
Yeah.
And that's actually a good heads up.
Cause like if you're like,
hey,
you already got the pullup bar and like the Jujitsu classes,
scout it out,
you know,
and then so you're just ready.
You're ready for the request because your kids are going to be,
they're going to,
they're going to want to get on the path.
Yeah.
And I think it was you,
I was telling this to where I was reading the part where he has to fix up his
bike.
The other one had spoiler spoil anything.
But anyway,
he needed money.
You need money.
So he's like,
Hey,
did you get money?
You got to,
you got to get a job.
And you know,
it lays out the whole thing.
All the layers of the thing.
That was pretty good.
So right after I was done with that chapter,
my five year old daughter,
by the way,
she looked,
kind of sits back,
almost disappointed looking.
She goes,
she goes,
I wish I had a job that was,
oh Dang.
I don't think I ever felt like man when I was telling a work ethic into a kid
that's five years old about wanting to work and wanting to work,
wanting to have a job and wanting to,
that's just like legit.
Yeah.
Yes.
Get those books where the work had marks mission
or you can also get the discipline equals freedom field manual.
I sounded a ton of those.
Again,
there's,
there's some people that that book hit them hard,
hard and they made some significant changes in their lives.
So everyone that came up to me and told me that,
thank you and I appreciate that feedback and it's awesome to see that book
hitting people the way that it hit me when I wrote it.
And it's awesome to see.
In fact,
that beginning part is what you're reading today.
There is no hack.
Yup.
There's no sweat lists.
Uh,
pursuit,
sweat lists,
sweat list direction definitely.
And then of course there's extreme ownership,
which was written by me and my brother Laid Babin
combat leadership for use in your business and life.
Then we also have this week just released,
so this,
this is live now at this time,
order it immediately.
The dichotomy of leadership.
A couple reviews already up there cause some people got some advanced copies,
awesome reviews.
Everyone is
stoked,
including including me and life.
You know,
we,
we wrote it and you know,
we'd edit each other and it'd be like burrowed nice chapter and be like,
Bro,
nice chopped her.
I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
so yeah,
we,
we critique each other and edit each other.
So the book is,
it just takes it to another granular level.
That's what it does.
It takes it down to another granular level,
I think.
And some people are saying that they're more,
people are going to get more out of the dichotomy of leadership than they don't
have extreme ownership.
They definitely compliment each other.
But there's a lot to be learned.
A lot of the mistakes that people make are going to be corrected through the
dichotomy of leadership.
Yeah,
yeah.
Cause you know,
when people would make a change in their,
whatever you know,
may make,
it's like,
what do you see?
Actually you're the first time I heard this over,
correct?
Correct.
Yes.
People will overcorrect people over correct all the time and they throw off the
balance of the dichotomy of leadership.
And so when you read the dichotomy of leadership,
you'll become aware of that.
You'll see what the signs are and you'll be able to correct him.
And this is gonna.
This is gonna really help out leaders in the world.
So dichotomy,
leadership available.
Now,
I haven't been think of that.
This book has been in the work for a long time and now it's out.
It's released.
It's in the wild.
So get some,
get some for your people you work with.
We appreciate that.
Support.
And then of course,
we've got a leadership company,
leadership consulting company,
Echelon Front.
Uh,
we solve leader,
we solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do.
It's me.
It's Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran,
Mike's Rally.
We also got Mike Barham on did you,
did you were,
you were there from like Bahamas part of roll call main gun,
Mike main gun,
Mike Wayne,
that I felt like I knew him already.
So we got another member,
army retired lieutenant colonel who was with us in the battle of Ramadi,
a company commander.
Then tanker and bad ass.
If you want,
if you need help leadership at your company with your team,
whatever it may be,
go to echelon front.com we've also got the mustard coming up.
Roll call's done.
Sorry.
You missed it.
It was awesome.
Come next time.
In the meantime,
muster zero zero six San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th
we're danger close right now.
I,
if you,
if you hear this podcast and you listen to it on,
you know,
in September,
hopefully,
maybe,
I dunno,
check the website,
extreme ownership.com all of them are sold out or danger close on this one.
But check it out.
We can sometimes squeeze in a few more seats.
And of course we also have EIF,
Overwatch.
Yeah,
overwatch.com this is for businesses,
for businesses that want
leaders tested,
battle tested,
special operations leaders from the special operations community or from a
combat aviation community.
You want those people,
those leaders at your business go to [inaudible],
overwatch.com that we are,
we have our friends,
our colleagues,
people we know our connections inside the special operations and inside the
combat aviation community.
They're trained,
they're ready and they will come and help your business through solid
leadership.
Again,
that's ETF,
overwatch.com and if you want to keep communicating with us then you can do it
through the interwebs,
through Twitter,
perhaps through Instagram or on the Phase II key.
Blah
echo is at echocharles and I am at jockowillink and thanks to all of you that
make this podcast possible and that's not some big corporate sponsor.
No,
it's the military personnel around the world that keep our country free.
It's all the first responders out there,
police,
law enforcement,
correctional officers,
firefighters,
border patrol,
paramedics,
all of you that keep us safe on the home front.
Thanks to all of you for what you do at everyone else.
That's out there.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you for spreading the word.
Thank you for supporting what we do,
but most of all,
thanks for telling yourself the truth.
Thanks for not looking for that sweat lists solution or that easy road because
the sweat list solution and the easy road don't exist.
To get on the path and to stay on the path that gets you to where you want to
be.
There is going to be sweat and there's going to be hard work and there's going
to be disciplined and you're going to have to look at yourself and tell yourself
the truth,
and then
of course
you're going to have to get after it.
Until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.